I know you can hear me right now cuz YouTube just prompt me to play an ahhh good morning
good evening, good afternoon, how the heck are you? have I slept? I'm still delirious
cuz it's not enough but I slept a considerable time I'm trying to sleep
at like 6 p.m. and then I can wake up at 4 fully refreshed
we're streamed? and I actually succeeded a little bit yesterday
um so I think I think I think I might be solving my my my problems with sleep
just like really hard I've just came online like 10 minutes ago and I've
just been sent the short of Emmy Farton I don't know if you want to hear the
audio of it she's not right I need to give it to her so she can thingy it but
I can send you I can let you listen to the audio of her Farton in a short if you
want to hear it to share the brap okay this is the Emmy short
I'm literally she's so proud of herself for Farton
I'm gonna send those on I say send them on I look I'll let you know some
behind-the-scenes stuff okay and the girls just wake up to new shit on their
channel okay they just wake up and I'm just like it's unlisted I'll unlist it
for Emmy because I know she likes things a certain way but I'll schedule it for
the others because they're just happy like with whoever not saying that he's not
happy I just understand that me likes things done a certain way so what I do
for Emmy is I name it I title it I tag it I describe it do the description for
her and then if she was changing anything she's more welcome to change
anything I came up with a bit of law for us reeflings yeah yeah our nicotine patch
has an internet connection that plays your VODs when you're offline yeah but
it's programmed to stop at your stream time which is why we get needy when
you're one minute late I mean we do have the perfect amount now for us being
needy so honestly I'm not over it
literally oh my god what I think please let me hold it is trending oh my god
wait what holy shit do you want to see these YouTube stars hold on talk about
not gatekeeping let me just take it that was my PC that made that noise not your
one it's mine talk about fucking both videos jumping in the algorithm hold on
let me pull this up let me pull this up because both my ASMR meme videos have been
caught in the algorithm sorry by date please oh my god they've both been caught
in the algorithm updating in real time so this is the last 48 hours see how God
I don't have a refund to point with right now trap top content real-time
copying has had 40k views in the last 48 hours that already had 10k views on its
own I think that's my is that my first 50k is more is it broke 50k girlfriend
begs you to let her hold it is that 80k I'm about to get 100k views on one ASMR
video holey moley
holy moley
fucking that's all so cozy true and replied to my tweet sorry we're having a
very slow start to the morning I need to wake up easy on me cozy true commented
on my tweets I was like all my videos being picked up in the algorithm and she
was like it's so nice when you get blessed by the algorithm this is an
example of if the algorithm didn't bless me I wouldn't be at the subscriber
thing and like everyone is pleading and begging with this machine to pick them
up this little zero bunch of zeros and ones to pick them up because if you do
get picked up I mean look at the fucking rewards you can reap like I better not go
ahead and me that's all I'm saying you better be subscribing to me visa right
no Emmy's still ahead good that's what I want to fucking see holy shit she was
about to hit 10k no that's fantastic oh my god she was about to hit 10k please
tell me I can redirect her into her after the stream if you aren't subscribed
to keep you she be caught in bum what are you doing with your life she is
literally what I'm supposed to be in another life and you know what to do
with that and you know what I mean by that we all understand what I mean by
that yes yes yes not your head not your head hold on please tell me I can be
direct into you second please please baby girl please tell me your stream and
second redirect into you apparently you're supposed to be doing an ASMR role
play but at what time she says that your usual pain nope nope I don't even see
the thumbnail hmm yeah she's in ASMR tours oh she better be I'm gonna cream all
over that bunny sorry that was really inappropriate I have to admit that one
was a bit of a thingy please don't be shy to subscribe to she be any of my
gen mates for that matter but she be is about to hit 10k which means the
management get to do a little celebratory 10k post and I mean Mercy's 1k
offer as well maybe a few good shorts and you never know and then we can all be
10k and we can all kiss and make out after 10k cream do you mean ink true
starting in drag with you haha I love the yellow or cuz we don't have HR so I
can sexually harass everyone and I can't get in trouble
anyway maybe we should play video game that was okay let me sip my tea
strong it is the HR literally oh you should hear the interview I'm like hmm
love you strongy love you too little refland good morning good evening good
afternoon I'm still getting called from Mercy yes we have been getting called a
little bit a bit rough but hey oh that's how that's just how it is
okay harass me mommy harasses all over you it's my idea HR lady drags you to
the office for to our word you now steady on these are these are patreon
honestly I wish I wish patreon would ease up understand that all hail or
mastercard overlords oh it's okay they all go in Epstein Island though but you
can't make a fantasy role play oh two consenting adults anyway that's just me
I don't know about you all hail visa so true pop-off mummy thank you you should
be like I like your funny words magic man how fast you grow honestly I am really
excited today cuz oh thank you tiny spainy for the tip sorry I didn't even
fucking thank you by name I was too busy focusing on your canon event that
you've got with book on microchips and I was the only reason I reject that lore
is because I am tinfoil huh I'm trying to put audio was amazing need to know
I think on Twitter if it's an artwork theme I want to ask I want to voice act
isn't there someone you forgot to ask oh we're out in the random payment for
the sensor honestly I wasn't able to participate in yesterday's educational
stream what did you miss you missed a prototype for streamings that I might do
in the future and there was a surprise pop quiz at the end but I gave you a hint
that there was a quiz at the end because at the start I said write your name at
the top of the paper and I actually had some reeflings genuinely like write down
their answers and show me and I was like oh my god this is the most adorable
thing I've ever seen in my life I love my life I love my reeflings everything is
good everything cool when you're part of the team you missed the biology
sociology exam and then a random lore dump about how the production of the
Hobbit was an absolute nightmare and I won't accept any Hobbit slander and
Toriel as well and all that I'm almost finished my tea I made a shit tea today
but then all the games at the top would just be
right so supermarket simulator apparently it's early access I don't know and I've
seen a lot of vtubers play it and you know we're just needing some casual
games I am going to be so depressed next week I should know my dad is already
he's just got here what kind of tea is everyday English breakfast tea or black
tea from other areas of the planet but we call it everyday English
breakfast tea and so apparently this is an infinite type of scenario so I don't
really know what's gonna happen now I don't know what we're gonna do we need
some milk on the shelves immediately well I have a clip of Azura playing this
game coming out and it was hilarious because the concept artist created an
asset in order to do this short and I swear to God if the short doesn't pop
off I'm gonna cry because it's actually a really good short I think it's really
good short Azura is actually hilarious if yeah if you and be patient on the
league streams and watch Azura stuff she's actually pretty hilarious on the
demo if you like this game you will love gas station simulator it's my
favorite chill game okay thank you bless the shimmy did Azura draw you is that
your profile picture did Azura do that thank you for the five bless the shimmy
yes I just needed some kind of shorter chill games for me old just cuz well my
dad is here and I actually I'm gonna be recording my dad names feature birds
today and I was so nervous originally I was gonna get people to submit
themselves but I realized it's not gonna work because my dad's gonna be fed up
after like the third model with like big fat and like boobs out he's gonna be
like I've had enough wrap up so I'm just gonna have to steamroll it basically
I'm gonna do obviously I'm gonna do indulge because he doesn't like so the
thing is I've shown dad I've shown my dad that I've shown everyone's designs I've
been like these are all my gen mates etc like I've explained to him like I've
explained to him I'm me and everything like that he would he wouldn't
recognize me in a lineup of feature price he wouldn't recognize it's me even
though I'm like yeah I'm green you know Celtic all that type thing he's like
who are all these slags they need covered up basically so I'm gonna have to
try and rush it and just shove in whoever I can get a good screen grab of I
might I might do the people that submit themselves for the VLR PNG review
rating thingy my bobber cuz I'm uh I'm wondering is it Elphin the Psyops one
I'm actually curious if my dad's gonna be like that looks like you
slag yes it is and a slang terminology for what VLR is a bunch of slag that's
terrible I'm so sorry let me finish this thing but yeah today I'm gonna record
that and I'm gonna have to like so I don't know if it the short is gonna be
successful or not so I technically I'm gonna record three max and see if I can
get away with it but I don't know how my dad's gonna do it because I need to
record the audio and then I'll need to go back and like lip-sync my model I
think and I don't know how to do it I don't know figure out figure out I'm
I'm praying for a splinter cell agent model splinter cell slang for a lovely
lady go go don't worry if you have to go understand my streamtimes aren't the
most friendliest to everyone so I do thank you just let him pilot your mecca
well ask them if they wanted to do it like just to see how it works like go
left and right in that and he's like no no no that's weird but he's happy with
what I do he's like he's happy I'm happy type thing because I was like oh it
universally thinks to like anyone's face as long as you've got eyeballs and it
knows what you're looking at slag is a roof refuse leftover from a large scale
forging honestly true slag super lovable amazing girl okay I'm about to start
commissioning a custom song at this rate and it's gonna be called slags and
that's right weird your slags your super lovable amies and get out your dad
sounds like a damn yes I am I've been very blessed in this life some people
have like some parents that aren't really being chiney and danger man but my
parents can are you sure you want to create a new saviour sorry I had to
test that it ran so if this explodes my PC okay welcome to supermarket simulator
you'll start with a small store and grow to an awesome supermarket start by
purchasing goods to sell and place them onto the shelves don't forget to set the
prices with a profit to avoid bankruptcy have fun okay no okay oh god that
actually need to framecap this stop that actually need to field of view
mouse sensitivity full-screen graphic wait you guys don't have a cap I know it
early access but I can't just manually cap it right not gonna lie I watched
someone play this because I didn't want to mess up what am I doing products burn
at your pain player my products right I had everything to cut okay and then
purchase oh I'm not I'm out of money don't purchase that don't purchase that
don't purchase that wait can I purchase anything cereal are we gonna be a
cereal only show off is that how poor I am so does this game have required
alcoholism for the retail workers steady on right so when you order it just spawns
oh wait hold on and you wet my whistle oh fuck I'm not Mary say I promise I can
whistle oh wait do you over say I can't whistle hold on right G throw open open
and then G drop please oh that's actually kind of satisfying hold on a
minute I can't call I couldn't do it oh of course I can do it now she's well
there we go there we go got it in the end nah she didn't turn around no she
doesn't want this she doesn't want the cereal that's fine that's fine right
let's set a price the average market cost is three quids I'm making it for
what's this closed all right to open it you need to this boom look at that oh man
you're quick geez good morning kind lady why yes of course beat money giving
change a dollar bill how did I give it over space to approve okay okay okay I
actually not doing that bad she wanted that so she spawned in for that mother
this we had to welcome to the cereal shop always wait do you hand over your
card in America did I tell you about that when I was a waitress an American
handed me God everyone is here for that series oh delicious gorgeous and they
handed me their cup how much did you give me 50 20 70 90 95 1 approve
okay now don't make me do mass again thank you and like he gave me his card to
sweat I'm like apparently like American cars don't have like chip and pin you
need to put a chip in in Britain yeah or else it doesn't work yeah my objective
all top left there's literally an objective prefer perform check out we
don't hand over cards when shopping anymore shop returned and should return
didn't pennies what's a chip it's called chip and pin the chip is the little
metal square on the card unless you don't have that no change giving oh my
god exact change thank you for your exact change good sir please have a
fantastic day if you don't give me exact change you're not welcome in my
store okay okay okay I love the card I love the card
boom just like that boom that's right oh yeah get them sales get them sales we're
looking low on supplies not gonna lie can you I'm stuck in him stuck I'm
actually stuck wait oh I just see a back out it's fine it's fine right hold
on we're gonna close thank you thank you everyone for your custom we need to
buy more cereal and stuff bye bye bye and buy more can I pay oh no I can't
afford all that I am right we're gonna first I'm just shy American need already
been a month hell yeah it's already been a month been a month all over your face
that's right take it okay I'm gonna say one thing about this game already I
think I'm actually gonna be really sorry this is such a cute freaking game I'm
already in love with it and we've just started I see now why this game has
beachabers no no this is wrong this is all wrong it's on the wrong shelf this
is I'm actually really enjoying this game lady I'm closed thank you you try to
steal merchandise I'm not having that right you're four bucks oh so you don't
have to set the price if it's on another shelf that's fine okay we're gonna
just do two dollars now this is a tactic called I don't have to do maths of
someone hands me cash if everything is in a full unit of like a quid okay so we
don't have to do math in it this way right sorry come in made it by a boy
here good afternoon sorry good morning sir thank you oh you just need a bread
for the day yep thank you okay well cheeky two dollar reduce thank you for
your custom appreciate it greatly thank you no no oh cereal and bread we are
called the breakfast shop we are leveling oh three whole items this is my
biggest order yet ten dollars thank you my autistic ass thought she was playing
Super Mario Simulator not yet two dollar bread in this economy honestly better
than the fucking bread prices in Australia it was thank you again American
need for the extended membership and it was very strange getting used to the
prices being double in Australia because Great British Proud to oh thank
you Trevor from GTA no no I don't give me cash what do you want change one two
three oh my god I'm actually getting so MLG at this game so I'm actually having a
lot of fun I don't know about you but I'm actually getting a bit of a serotonin
boost playing this game I'm understanding now I understand I'm so sorry
VTubers why do I doubt when a game gets popular this is gonna be me on secure
a like is it no so weaker so weaker literally I don't know why I doubt
VTubers so as you all have good taste I take everything back what I said you
guys have such good taste Stony's natural town to the high table activities
don't say such things don't say such things such horrible things to me okay
back to our see you later see you later I'll get you're in a while cockadeit
fucking hell the shine on that you mind mr. Sun goodness gravy there's no such
thing as like old stock right I'm not gonna like have a rotted stock four
dollars please thank you oh thank you for your custom give me a bit cash no
change exact change love you love a sexual harassment on the side I'm level
two in the store I don't know what that means I'll work your shift if you let me
bring a stool do you guys remember the Korean streamer that used to stream from
a convenience store I could it was she's called like that absolutely a dorder and
I've not had time to watch her in ages but obviously if you didn't know Korean
twitch in Korea shut down because of the weight why is it so dark in here and
no one's gonna want to come into a dark shop it looks like I'm trying to mug of
them via bread and fucking why is it so dark I'm so sorry we can't afford light
bulbs I don't know how to put the lights on there's lights but they're not coming
on it's so dark in here it looks like I'm trying to shank them they're surely
oh okay it was so dark for no reason right we're running low on stock but I'm
gonna close in a second Danny to like go asleep in this game or is this game
just like do you want that was sorry that like so scary from the outside in
like oh yeah wait hold on I can't get out I forget to say wait sorry sorry there's
one more customer how many cuttlefish does it take to turn on a light bulb
brov honestly right are you gonna finish he bought this dog thank you thank you
so much I appreciate that greatly yes thank you right close we're close get
out there's no stock get out yeah yeah you better be scratching your head and
where's the stock and up Mars and right how do I do this one two three four five
six no I can't afford it right we'll get rid of oil cuz our money it's closed
after 9 p.m. please look at the top right oh my god I just realized you can't
see my most cursory in game I don't know if you see that hold on hold on you
might need to see my most cursory in game that game is a low capture crush
game there we go you can see my most there it says closed after 9 p.m. and
that's 9 p.m. right there yeah talk about being unlucky
duck can I go to sleep or something there's like press enter to finish the
day okay okay we had 19 store points supply costs toll profits $32 you've
received daily bill oh no I can't just finish the capital list
are you squidding me right now they're not for sale steals strongies punts and
runs and they're not for sale you can't just give me two dollars and expect me
to be happy about about go towards my bills so I'll live at this time Bob
thank you I'll like how your profile picture is good off outside on the
freaking porch via a ring cam that's amazing thank you right you'll receive
daily bills starting today make sure you pay those bills using your computer
before their due date or they'll be paid automatically the more
electronic call devices the more expensive the bills right we need to
we need to be lucky to split pronto on putting stuff on the shelves cuz I love
this sorry this is actually so satisfying like oh my god yeah oh look at
that look at that oh oh then shove it in the bin shove it in the bin should be
recycling but I'll let it slide this time shove it in the boom shove it in the
boom I fucked up on that shelf but that's okay so this is actually so
satisfying I actually can handle this right I guess we're sugar is going down
there even though I tended it to go in the thing to do bucks for pants is a
steal what is the average e-girl charge for pants so for no particular reason at
all maybe that's I should open up a shop and it's just all the girls's pants that
are used I said what I said sorry it would be good business I don't care
right I've not right average place of flowers so just round up to a buck
and two bucks just round everything up and past the two bucks I guess cuz
making a dollar wait so then what should flowers be two bucks I'm not aim is
gonna buy that but sure if you want you didn't have right what is this oh sorry
right no ordering is it management for my bills my bills are paid my bills are
paid wait so we're you can hire people growth section to purchase a section to
expand your supermarket storage is locked 800 dollars do's for storage and
not a bear to just shove stuff on the fence hey on the big game I would buy
that for a friend yes for a friend you're still under the market for two
dollars at flower am I actually oh sorry whoa okay actually it looks like you
get like way more money changes 84 50 70 80 1 2 3 4 yeah that's how I did
maths in my head I don't know how you do it but I do it like that because 5 plus
2 is 70 but 5 plus 3 is 8 wait I said that wrong I said it right on my head
though that's the main thing 1 2 3 boom I said it wrong out loud but I said it
right in my head okay please don't bully me I'm sorry I promise if I'm your cash
here I'm actually not that bad I'm not that bad if I'm your cashier okay okay
right oh my god yes please buy all my stonks invest in money eight bucks for
all of that honestly this place is a steel sauce I'm actually visiting it
right 10 and 1 2 3 4
what okay thank you for your custom I appreciate it 12 dollars our biggest
transaction yet thank you madam we really do be living in a card society
whoa they put the detail in to give her a tramp stamp based on red pill the
development team what the heck they give people tramp stamps here not bad purchase
product license using the computer product license purchases license to
be able to sell product 200 dollars oh oh you need no because products have to
actually pay the supermarkets to get put on the shelves gen 2 tramp stamp do
you want one I mean I can make it happen I guess you know Emmys Emmys
technically the only one to have a tattoo at this point and it's more of a
brand to be honest like she got branded when her Bruce he popped his clogs but
don't worry I'll work it in a damn everyone loving them sugar what cash
would you like one two three four boom just like that easy peasy and I made
four dollars profit granny scrawny noises oh thank you for holding your
card out for me oh my god sorry this game is actually so fun
does anyone smell a HR case or is it just me that is don't laugh at that that's
terrible okay don't laugh at such things right we need 200 freaking dollars
bro what is the price of sliver Danny like to put it up the market price is
three bucks wait why am I charging so little then right well we'll undercut the
market that's fine are we undercutting you the average price of sugar is 4 no
we'll undercut but my 396 no we'll do three dollars but oh my gosh what are
you five 598 for a box of cereal you guys are having an absolute laugh sorry
but okay that makes sense why I'm not getting a lot of money that quick because
I'm being too nice okay that's right I've become the very sweet what do you want a
dollar all yours and I've become the very thing I swore to destroy this game
man inflation hit hard let's say I'm like other shops are charging but I mean if
it gives me an extra bucks here and there then maybe we can get that license by
the end of the day thank you you want five bucks change all yours no crap I
need to order more stuff before the end of the day I'd rather just buy a ton of
stock for tomorrow because I don't think I'm gonna make that 200 bucks no change
okay thank you I'm gonna very quickly order stonks order stonks quick quick
market you you you you you you I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming just a
moment please just a moment just a moment hold on thank you thank you for
waiting I do appreciate that totally wasn't goofing off on the computer
looking at YouTube videos to keep myself entertained look at the boxes we're
so patiently waiting for me to stack them
scrawny I swear I'm not a capitalist cause how dare you the sacrilege I won't
take him oh also she bees emotes are up mercies there's an edit to Zura's emotes
and there's an edit to mercies emotes and then that's all the base emotes done
and then the girls can ask for whatever emotes space they have squid me right
which is coming comes back steals strong is socks and runs away you can't
keep giving me two dollars from my apparel okay you I'm I oh god we're in
the dark again oh hold on hold on let me fucking put okay there we go if someone
gonna steal my boxes they better know I'll be wait oh sorry sorry sorry I'm here
and give me exact change thank you kiss you kiss you on your lips right we do
still have some stock left I might just sit there as good as all are you thank
you for yonking my socks Bob Bob Bob Bob yes that's how I would say your name
Bob we should name B.O.B. so they call in you Bob thank you yeah okay we're now
making four okay hold on hold on right let me get off this oh are you joking
time and make time and hurry up it's like literally about to be bedtime go to
bed go to bed here's your dollar back no oh right okay I'm just gonna right I've
had enough I've had enough finish up what you're doing buy what you want hurry up
I need to restock the dang shelves all yours and you give me exact change thank
you what about you my lady come my lady come come my lady you my sugar flat my
butter my baby that's actually not the words at all okay let's very quickly
restock the shelves before well that was a really terrible way of doing it I
what I can't stop doing it that way though but it's so satisfying put things
on the shelves look oh my god look at that are you squid me right now look at
that where you still our hearts a few socks is a fair exchange oh thank you
for the 30 I'm closed geez you can't see me restocking over here I'm at an
exhausted college student trying to pay my bills because I never got the
scholarship in the tri-state area and also the neighborhood watch and and the
freaking Independence Day or something I don't know some times you guys come out
with really interesting stuff thank you for the 30 I know and that was big just
wallop in your fat 30 30 inch or just like that what are these oh y'all then
then right you've got price you've got price you've got price you've got price
doll right the average first and past us three bucks so I'll just do three bucks
and then our oil is 450 relax let's make it for my gosh you know we can pass the
savings on to you looking ass in the tri-state area I have no idea like what's
going on what so I can just replace the okay I can take the tag off if it's like
not there anymore right I have $50 reduce let us go to the next day that I don't
30 wants to pay for the pants right what's the deal day to satisfy customers
23 products found expensive products not found short changed God I'm actually
somehow not short-changing people store level I guess you can probably get more
unlocks a higher level you are income 148 supply cost all profit minus 29 bucks
but my balance went up huh huh supply cost but income is that because I bought
all that stuff but didn't sell it yet so the games like market price has changed
for the following products flower has gone down well we're still fine you start
the day with no stock okay right boom everyone come in right now I am buying
this product licensing next thank you thank you management purchase oh I'm not
money enough okay that's fine bills a whole dollar I mean we're gonna be in
trouble with that one hello strongy I heard that you found oil oh thank you
United States of America please don't worry there was a little bit of oil but
just to weave it thank you for your very kind generous tip in exchange for the tip
that I know where oil is yes yes thank you thank you
not sorry I'm gonna say it this game is giving me serotonin I don't know why it's
so satisfying I get a little easy money in the till money money number go up what
do you mean number go up serotonin go up I can't believe it this game is a slow
burner I bet you it's even more satisfying when you like open up a massive
like thing oh she's like corporate executive look at them heels and that
blazer fantastic outfit design we're rating it right now 10 out of 10 it's so
cohesive the outfit beautiful stunning you want five bucks no you want seven all
yours I can do it in my head but I can't do it out loud a little cheeky card 13
bucks that's our highest one yet as a I think one dollar change all yours sir
thank you thank you for supporting the shop we still need 200 bucks to upgrade
the next objective I knew this game was gonna get you who do you like this kind
of gameplay what do you mean games that don't require intense reaction time and
actual game skill are good for me I can't believe it oh we were so close to a
good shot but we didn't get it I can't believe they thought of it oh that was
15 bucks we don't think we've made 15 yet a little bit of oil yes a little bit of
oil why of course my good sir you could sell condoms to a nun what the fuck
where did that come from I'm not a good saleswoman are you joking I'm like the
worst saleswoman come get your bread it's lower than market price you might
still show up to my shop that's like that best I can do I don't think I could
actually consider people to buy stuff $8 he does all for you madam I just got
an achievement I don't know what it is because my tracker is right in the way
$11 thank you we're almost at 200 bucks 125 copium copium we're gonna make it
we're gonna make it we just need $200 and then we can purchase the license on
the computer you sold six virtual Wi-Fi's to me strongy and I don't even have a
product you just wait until that flesh comes out that's awful do not listen to
a thing that comes out of my mouth that is absolutely horrific please please
welcome good morning thank you for your custom thank you for supporting a
local business instead of a conglomerate of a monopoly yes thank you I'm just a
little guy I pay taxes did you know that when you're fucking when you know when
supermarkets prompt you to donate don't ever do it they claim that as their
taxes because they get a tax rebate on a donation and they put it against the
taxes they should be paying but because they're a freaking conglomerate thank you
for supporting a small business do appreciate you oh oh big order thank
you what do you need $5 change there is that was our biggest sale yet thank you
paying taxes and my strongy stream this man loves this cereal donations are
tax loopholes so whenever fast food joint that is massive or a supermarket
that is massive goes would you like to donate to the starving children no but
not for that reason okay you're allowed to donate in general but not via the
supermarket because they use it as a freaking tax rebate okay so don't don't
support via the supermarket if you want to support in general that's fine but
say now let them kids starve they're literally guilt-tripping you let them
motherfuckers yes if you really wanted to donate to directly to charity but the
biggest way I think the biggest way you can help out the community is
unironically just oh we've got 200 bucks couldn't find pasta well your momma
right you management product license oh yeah purchase a fridge a fridge I have
like Danny put that stuff in the fridge sorry thank you good sir thank you good
sir I need to sell some stuff I need to be I like have no money for supplies I
think at 8 o'clock I'll shop very quickly and I'm like running really low on
surprise but I'm really low on money for the supplies six dollars please no
change thank you good sir couldn't find the pack I get it I get it I get it I get
it I'm out past that right everyone go home what did we unlock bottled water
cheese coffee dark roast boy if you don't get eggs eight pack milk tea right
we've never sold tea we've not sold water I think I need a fridge for the other
stuff what how much oh my gosh sorry we need to go nice and cheap oh my god
right past those cheap should we just like ball in the cheap stuff I think we
need to kind of ball purchase why can I not purchase are you joking no take away
some of it they are purchased okay I have it I have stuff for tomorrow that's
the main every time I do this every time I'm like that creepy guy like lurking in
the shop just like yeah you like that right pasta goes up here so everyone
can see it since you're all complaining cheese pasta is your biggest sailor is
actually okay all on this shelf and then one above and then you can all see it
super duper easily oh more flour just when you think there wasn't enough yeah
yeah yeah I caught you trying this I caught you trying to thief okay don't
think I'm not on to you this product needs to be in a fridge close and draw in
a fridge no why no bottled water does they need to be in a fridge oh my god I
got too much flour I didn't realize how cheap it was to restart use dry okay our
supplies are a bit merda if I removed these people aren't gonna complain that
the product isn't on the shelf right that's how it works right right right
No not the water it's gonna be warm liquids have to be refrigerated
Oh yeah? Then explain your balls. What the heck?
Don't think I'm gonna fall for your foolish ambitions, Wiefling.
Products not found!
How... what am I... am I playing this game wrong? I'm getting... I'm getting... I'm getting nervous.
Why is everything going horrifically wrong? Where everyone's getting the shot right now.
How much is a fridge? Furnit your... shelves?
A display fridge? A fridge single. Another $200?
Oh that's quite a tall order, sorry. But like, look at my... how...
I'm to get a fridge on flour alone. Good morning. Please tell me you don't want anything out of the...
Okay, that's fine. You're allowed pasta. I... I give you permission to have pasta.
Thank you for your custom. Here's a dollar change.
I don't sell cheese! There's no indication of cheese being sold in the shop.
You're not allowed to ask for products, ma'am, that we don't sell. Miss, get back here. I will fistfight
you in the back in the parking lot. Get back here. We don't sell cheese. There's no indication we
should be selling cheese. Do you know what my license is? Are you the person I bought the
freaking license from? Relax. It's not that serious. It honestly isn't. Oh, I can't even find the cheese.
Yeah, nay, shite. There's nay fucking fridges. Of course there's nay cheese. Do you know how hot
it is outside? Like, honestly, the whole world doesn't revolve around you, ma'am.
Strong behavior. I didn't know... I didn't know they were allowed to be demanding, like,
oh, but she could sell cheese. Now, it'd be different if they were like, oh, I can't wait
for you to expand to sell cheese, but oh, there's nay cheese. Of course there's nay cheese. Are you
gonna pay for the fridge? It's 200 quid. I've not got 200 quid via flour sales unless you want to,
like, open up a bakery and use me as your supply chain. Sure, you can complain then,
but are you freaking kidding me? Like, honestly, that absolute cheek of some folk.
Good afternoon, sir. Sorry about that outburst. I was just talking to my co-worker on the headset.
I promise I wasn't having a random mental health breakout burst. Right, we are gonna need more
products. Just shove anything in here. Right, we can't sell cheese because everything needs water.
Eh, I need a shelf apparently. No, not right now! Okay. Could you imagine a customer and we're just
going, you can take your money back by right-clicking on the bills on the cash register. Oh, did I make
a mistake? I don't know. Change a dollar. Did I make a mistake? Couldn't find the sliced bread.
Yeah, because I don't sell it! Jeez. Jeez, you guys are like so needy, honestly. Right, bread?
You want bread? What, you want cereal? Cereal's $41? Oh my lord, I don't have that kind of money.
Oh my god, I need to hire someone else to do the machines, honestly. Insufficient change.
How do I put it back? Put it back. Put it back. Close checkout, approve. Back. How do I put it back? Oh no.
What? What do you need? Giving $7? Right, hold on. Let me do it like this. Sorry, sorry. Hold on.
Bink, won't bink. Okay, sorry. I hadn't. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Couldn't find the milk. Fond de la bosom.
Tomato tomato. Just, just enjoy the stock for what it's worth, honestly. I ain't got time. I don't have
time. I need to hire someone else to do this. Reflens, will you come work in a convenience store
with me? I need your help. I don't have time. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. The cheese. Why is
everyone addicted to cheese? I thought you were all lactose intolerant by like 50% of the nation
become, who knocked over my packages? I thought everyone becomes lactose intolerant like so quickly.
Okay, drop. Just shove it on the floor. Good afternoon. Hello, thank you for your custom.
You would like $2 change. Oh, here it is. Thank you, veiler lover for the extended membership. Just
imagine these are needy reeflings waiting for your next audio, honestly. Everyone like excited
for the next audio and then it's me with a dick. Oh, everyone was like absolutely like, oh, so
disappointed. Oh, thank you for the exact change, sir. Thank you. Thank you. Who is knocking over
my packages? Please don't do that. Can I restock? No, I put it on the bottom shelf. I suck. No,
I'm not ready yet. I'm not ready yet. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Gee, shove
on the floor. Hello. Good afternoon. Bing, bing, bing. All yours. All yours, baby. I'm restocking
whilst on the job. I'm actually so good at this. Sorry. I'm such a good multitasker. Did you know
that it is a common misconception that women can multitask more, but actually it's just practice
behavior because yeah, you can't, I don't sell tea. I didn't know they could be so cheeky and ask
for stuff I didn't even sell, honestly. I've got nothing but the cheek you lot do, honestly,
honestly, honestly. I'm on to you. I'm on to you. Didn't think I'm on to you. Sorry, I need to clean
up the storage. Excuse me, sir. Sorry, just a moment. Just a moment. Can you run in this game?
That'd be really helpful. Don't ding that bell. Don't ding the bell on the register. I'm just
about to be there. Please give me a second. Thank you. Buy a boh here. I bet him buy a boh here.
I know you couldn't find the bottled water because it's in a package that you'll never know about.
No.
I'm just buying everything. Okay. I'm here and the lights are getting Friday nights and the lights
are low. Hold on. I need to put the lights on. It's so dark, my lady. That audio is not my cup
of tea, but I'm still gonna listen to it. Are you even though you don't like it? Thank you.
It's not for everyone. It's not for everyone, but I do have some outrageous
audios coming out soon. Thank you, Broly Legend for the tip and for giving it a shot. I mean,
some people are like, so they're like, I would never listen to this. It's disgusting. I'm like,
bro, relax. I'm literally pretending to have a willy. It's not that serious.
What do you mean you don't want me to clap your cheeks? If reeflings come work for you,
you require good benefits. You can't provide those right? Winking face.
What kinds of benefits would you like anonymous is the question? I mean, there's not as long as
you don't report it to HR. There's not much that I'm not happy with, you know? $9, $5, 1, 1, 1, 1. Boom.
If I read cheese one more time, I'm gonna shove cheese up someone's arse.
Let's just very quickly purchase all this shit and then I can put it on the shelves.
Oh, no, let's stay open because there's a customer. Open.
I was anything but disappointed with the latest audio,
Mama. In fact, I was elated that I had the house to myself so I could use my new figureine to it.
No. My figureine died, though, and I have to try again another day.
No.
Your figure died?
I would love to work in your store, Mama. I'll handle the heavy packages as long as you handle my heavy package.
You don't even have to pay me. I just want to ogle at my little seed.
Okay, that was actually really good. I'll give you that. That was really good.
God, some late night shoppers, huh? Burning the midday oil. Go home.
Jeez. Oh my. What? How? It must be because they're spawning around the corner.
Jeez, you guys don't love your families? My goodness. Thank you so much. Anonymous.
I have really weak wrists and hands, so unironically, I will take that help. I'm so freaking weak.
I'm a weakling, okay? I'm a weakling. A weak little seaweed. It's shocking behavior.
The Rizzler. Thank you. Orvon Biscuit as well. How did it die is my question.
And what? How did it die? It's got a... Not that word. It's got a battery in it. Is that my question?
What was that meme that it's like, oh, so a woman can have a d-d-d-d-d-9000, but if I have a d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-x
elemental pee, I'm the weird one. What is that meme that has just reminded me of that meme? I can't
remember it though. Family who sent them to the corner. Oh my god, my mom used to send me the
corner shop to get cigarettes all the time. Actually, I will say one thing about the Belgians.
You guys are so nice, because I didn't have my ID in this Belgian lady. Let me buy cigarettes.
And she was like, you look too young. And I'm like, hee hee, but I'm from Scotland though.
I was like, I'm from Scotland, so no one's going to get you in trouble.
And like, I literally started speaking to her and I was like, yeah, I don't speak Dutch. I'm not
from here. I literally just need cigarettes. Smile. Thank you, Maycule, for becoming a member. I
appreciate it. I'm sorry for butchering your name. Please forgive me. Right, tomorrow we can purchase
the fridge. So our beloved package of, that's just, that's being chilling in the corner. Right,
we can have cheese tomorrow. Okay, let's go to bed. Oh wait, no, do we have bills?
Alone? No, we're not taking out a loan. We hate the banks. Oh my god, 67 cents. Wait, every day
it's gonna cost me 20 bucks. Judy, that's rough. I don't make 70 bucks on every purchase. Right,
new name, new date. Stop, I'm getting ready to write that plot. Stop, you're getting me ready
to write that plot. Oh, don't think I won't do it. Don't think I won't write that plot. That's
absolutely hilarious. Oh, I like a little guard as well. I don't even notice I've got a little guard
to protect me from the customers from this side. I will literally thank you for the tip and honest.
I will write that. Please don't think I won. I'm literally, I love like freaking plots that we do
together. It's my favorite thing. This woman truly will do it. Do it, you won't know boss. Shake bag
if you didn't. Shake bag if you didn't. Don't throw it at us with a good time. Hello, any customers?
Are you my first customer? Actually, I've never even, we must be in New York because those things
like the fire exit things always look like they're from New York. Oh, we have a customer. Are you
squidding me right now? Hi, mama. I just tuned in. I just wanted to say you stole my heart during
yesterday's stream when you read my morrow before you logged off. Turning on your hypno eyes and
talking about control was so unbelievably hot. Now I really want to ink in your clown.
I mean, I can make something like that. Are you squidding me right now? Oh, honestly, I can.
Don't think I won. Yes, it had a battery. I thought it would work better than the unpowered ones I
tried in the past, but didn't find enjoyable using them by myself. Oh, we're getting a live review.
I need mommy's help to enjoy my cheeks being clapped.
That is terrible. Amazing. Thank you.
Oh, thank you for the tip anonymous and out of on biscuit.
No, so obviously, I can't really make anything and I can't record new ASMR until my dad goes away,
but he goes away next week. I'm actually going to be so depressed. So don't be surprised when I
when I stream and for like 12 hours, and then I'm like, I don't want to go offline because
I don't want to be sad in my emotions the moment I go offline because like I'm never sad when I'm
like streaming to you. And like I'm always happy like just like having the time of my life. So I
just know I'm going to be so depressed, but I'm happy on stream. But as soon as I end stream,
like it's literally going to be that meme where it's like with the music, like I'm not going to
I'm not going to be having a good time next week, but you guys will make it that have a good time.
And you know, I know you guys will make a good time. So I need just as needed as we fling.
I mean, I think that's why we work so well together. We fling. I mean,
you know, you don't report me to HR. We do some things in the break room, you know,
I don't report you for something, something, something, something, something.
I am happy to help you in the shop. And as payment all I ask is that you give me some
cream like you did in the recent order. Honestly, do you want some creamer for your
coffee in the morning at my supermarket? We'll call it. What would we call it? Oh, you can't rename
it. Oh, I thought what is city gates? City gates. Um, I what would we name the shop though? If we
had one. Squid ink. A dollar for you, madam. Thank you for your custom. Right. We're at 100
bucks. We just need a few more sales, please. Squirts. You want, you want this supermarket
to be called squirts? Oh no, this can't be. You can see ink. Coldstone creamery. I'm not sure
we're going to get a wave. Although, can we make one of those cringy American ads? Jones, barbecue
foot massage. And then our version is like, uh, Strone and Reflings, Inc. Emporium or something
like that. I don't know what we'd call it. Ink mark. Well, like ink mark. Strone and Reflings,
ink mark. Come on down to get your things. Come on down to get your things. We're anti-capitalist,
but we still have to participate in society. But it's okay because our prices are lower than
the monopolies. That's our theme song. It's like the worst jingle you could imagine. And everyone's
like, why did they put ads into this? This is awful. Honestly. Thank you. Oil, oil, oil. I know
you Americans like your oil. Take it. Take all my oil. Right, $137. We're almost there. Thank you
for your purchases. $17. Oh, nope. I almost messed up so bad. Sir, you have no idea how much I
about overcharged you. You're so welcome. I was on it. Are you squidding me right now? You charged
him $0.09? Hi, Mama. I remembered you once said that Reflings are able to hypno you just like
you can hypno us. Yes. Can you teach us how? A mind broken straw knee would be amazing to see,
to see our cheeky little less get addicted to Reflings ink. I'm already addicted to,
you only send a man of marshmallows. I demand marshmallows.
So technically you can hypnotize me at any time, but in my head, I've done it that you prefer to do
it via a mirror because you like when I do it to myself, like it's more satisfying for you
that way. I'm not going to run out of freaking things. Thank you for the hypno.
Top tier servicing. No matter how big or small, we work until you're satisfied.
And I don't think the work is talking about the average nine of five.
Call it ink and drink. Thank you. Lars the dude for the tip. Yeah, I'm not convinced you're talking
about the average nine to five work. I think we're talking about another kind of work. You know what
I'm saying? How's the weather in Australia? Are you okay Reflings? Did you get a little
nervous typing that out? Thank you for letting me pop your super cherry. Oh, no, no, you're,
I said that wrong. I said that wrong. Sorry. Other me. Thank you for letting me pop your
super cherry. No, you're super cherry. I'm so sorry. That sounded like an insult. I didn't mean
it like that. It's winter. So it's cold. It's cold. Okay, eight dollars. Did that charge anything
for that? Did I just let you walk out for free? I think I did. I think I messed that up.
Your mega chair, your super mega cherry is main boy. You're not getting away from me that easily.
Right. Okay, we're done. We can buy a fridge. I assume I can buy a fridge or do I need to do it in
the morning? Here is the fridge. A mini fridge. Okay. Oh crap. I have to do it in the morning.
We'll also add a product into it. What are we missing?
Oh my God, please. You're welcome to buy anything you like. Buy everything. Yes, yes. Okay, I'll
take it. Three items are better than one. You know what I'm saying? Thank you for your custom. I
couldn't find sushi, even cheese. How come you didn't mention that you can speak French? Because I
can't. I can say like one or two sentences and I can throw stuff together. It's pretty much it.
I can't actually speak French. I can say like, oh, je voudrais, you know, tabit. I can ask for
your cock. I can ask for your horse in French. To say butt in French, you say cool. Thank you,
dindle shit, 500. What a name for the super chat, by the way. You're super chat cherry.
Yeah, to say your butt, you say mon cul. Are you squiddling me right now?
So, Strani, if we already have the capability to hypno you, does that mean we can turn on mind
broken Strani whenever we want? Do we snap our fingers? Say a certain phrase?
Um, so if you've ever looked, ah, you know what? I'll show you. This is my loading screen. Look at
you in the loading screen. Oh wait, this is my ending screen. I know you can still hear me in this,
but yeah, you can. See how you're on my head right now in here? Wait for it. Wait for it.
Look at you. Look at you on the top of my head. Ready, steady. We both have hypnosis.
Look, you have the hair thing like I do. Yeah, you got the little hair thing,
little hypnotic thing. Yeah, it's real. That's you. You can do that to me and I can do it to you.
I forgot which gaming thing I was on. Like I'm on this one. Oh, where's my game?
Well, we're not doing that again. That was scary, please. That scared me. Right,
we've got a fridge and we've got 13 bucks so we can order bread and then tomorrow we can purchase it.
Okay, and it's only $2 for delivery. That's fantastic. Closed. New day. New day. Right,
we're going to very quick. Products found expensive, so is, but no from the, not from around here,
partner, not from around here. Right, hold on. Give me the fridge right now. It's a fridge. Oh my
head, rotate with mouse wheel. Okay, can I slot you right here? Oh my god. Display is full. Wait,
the fridge is tiny. She said she was 12. Sorry, I said it like that. Hold on. Open. No, draft.
Some products went down in price but you didn't follow. How dare they? They're making,
they're making a mockery of me. They're making a mockery. Right, I only have two dollars. Right,
let's set a price for the water. Water. Market price is $2.13, so we'll do two bucks. What are you?
We need to lower the oil. Of course, I invest in tons of oil in the games like, yeah, we're
going to just artificially lower the price. Right, bread's up at four bucks. Yeah, nine.
What's flour? Okay, flour's fine. Flour's fine, don't worry about it. Okay, hydration check,
reeflings. Hydration check. Hydration.
I'm gonna burp okay. Open your mouth, reefling. Open wide. All yours, baby. Good boy for opening
your mouth. It's fucking disgusting. That's actually disgusting. You know what, you know what
the worst part is when I do something like that, like a gag like that? Oh, hit me on one.
Hi, I'm a first-time customer for this establishment and I was wondering if you
sold any exotic items. Maybe a dog, collar, and bowl. Sound familiar, Stronny?
Okay, if you didn't know, I may or may not have an alternative Twitter account, okay,
and I may or may not have purchased a collar. Oh, give me that back. Oh, you know what,
fuck it, you can have it for free. Thanks for your custom. I may or may not have bought a dog
bowl and a dog collar with your name on it because you own me. So some people were like,
oh, you need to put like Stronny on it. But if you own me, I should technically have your name
on me. So I have a bowl coming with your name on it. And that's, I don't know if the collar's
going to say property of refling or just refling. I hope it says property of refling because I'm
going to come so fucking hard whenever I, you guys are getting the audio where you can literally
hear it like jingling on my chest. Or maybe I should put it on and then you can hear me put it on.
I like it. Bit bread, bit bread, a little dollar change for you ma'am. Stronny, what? No, Ms. Mano,
you're not supposed to be here. Ms. Mano, Ms. Mano, I'm just, I'm confessing, Ms. Mano, I'm confessing.
The accuser, purchase a new section in your computer. I heard all that. No, Ms. Mano,
that's even more embarrassing. Oh, I'm just gonna, I need to expand growth.
I could probably change it. I have enough time. Did I goof? Shit. Did I mess that up? Am I supposed
to be strong on it? Am I that brain dead? The answer, yes. I unknowingly pulled up to the freaky
store apparently. Stop. No, this is Squid Mart. Welcome to Squid Mart where all your needs are
met. Are you okay? Ma'am? Oh my God, is she okay? Are you okay, ma'am? Ma'am? What do you need?
Are you being assigned? I think she's been assigned something on the shelf.
I'll help the AI. Don't worry, I'm here. Oh, oh, she, I didn't know they had, you know,
crackheads in this game. That's terrible. Do not use such derogatory terms for people who are
afflicted with the older addiction. That's terrible. I don't think she's feeling that good,
I'm gonna be honest. Oh, my needs, go on. Can't make up her mind. Thank you, tiny spiny for the
tip. Okay, I will get that changed. There's more than enough time. I promise there's more than
enough because I only just did it. So I'm sure I can like change it because it gets custom made and
they had like a big warning that was like, oh, you need to give us like plenty of time.
And vitamins to ensure our inks of THR best quality and potency. You only get two days a month after
all. Squid mark for all your inking needs. Not you guys learning. Oh, reluctantly saying that was
such a good bit. I love that. Not you guys learning about ovulation. Thanks to me. Oh, are you guys
okay? God, there's two now. What have I done wrong? I'm not sure what I've done wrong, if I'm being
honest. Right, the light's going on now. So this place isn't freaking dark. And you just put it on
all the time. Damn, you and Belgan called it. She's undecided on what's a better product.
Bro, they're literally, I don't, the AI is having a hard time with the oil right now.
I'm not really sure why. Come on, AI. Look at them heels though, heels. Oh, and they put in
height differences. Honestly, this has been quite a decent bit of, considering this is early access,
I mean, I would say it's pretty polished. Am I, am I going crazy? I know I shouldn't encourage,
but if it's not like a mega-cabillion thingy, I don't think it's actually a bad rate. If you
two, are you two, can you get out of me right now? Don't listen to them. I like property of
reefling on the collar. I can imagine giving it a little tug and pull you in for a deep,
passionate kiss and a hard spank to your cuttlefish arse. Be a good little pet for me, strongy.
Are you squiddin' me right now? Right, well, I get two versions. I can get two versions. No cheese,
one star review. Stop. I'm working on the cheese, okay? A customer's out the, you guys weren't there
for ages. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. I can't read chat. Oh, no, no. Fuck it. Take it. Take the change.
You're welcome. Oh, you're going to complain after I give you extra change? Go away. Thank you so much.
Red flame kraadin. Kraadin? Where are you from? Kraadin. Red flame kraadin. What? Why do I think
you're European? That's right. I've sussed you out. I'm coming to your house. What are you going to
do about it? I can just shortchange that person. You're selling a product without... Oh, and you
would buy four of them. I've not set the price. Oh, jeez. How do you do this? Oh my god. Oh my god.
I've not set the price. Don't go for the cheese. Don't go for the cheese. Don't go for the cheese.
I've not set the price. Cheese. Three bucks. Go. Of course you'd buy the fucking cheese.
I've not set the price. Your mum, yeah? Customer Greg? No way your name is actually
customer Greg. Please tell me you changed that to do that super chat. Is your name actually
customer Greg? That's your online handle. That's hilarious. Thank you for your one star review.
I'm trying my best, okay? Couldn't find the black... That's what I think about you, honestly. I'm fucking
getting tired of this shit. Everyone's so needy for a product I don't sell and they should have no
indication that I freaking sell it, honestly. Snowberries. Skippity. Why did you put on skippity?
That's going to be stuck in my head now. No, don't type that. Hi, snowberries. How is acicle stream?
Was she having fun with you? Was she tormenting you? Was she teasing you? Was she pleasing you?
That's what I like to hear. How could this delicious brat be so
gorgeous? Yeah, actually it's the other way around to do. I think the tormenting was the other way
around. You tormenting my precious little acicle? How dare you? Unless she likes it and that's
different. Well, there's cars in this game. I mean, in all honesty, what do they have to do
to polish off this game? I mean, the method seems to work of the shop. Am I going crazy
and saying that this game really isn't that bad? Storage? I'm not going to bother with that. Just
seems like $800 for nothing. I don't know. Maybe it comes more... Is this a staff room?
Unironically, is this a toilet? This is where me and the reeflings go after a long day.
It's just a helping hand. It's levitating. Look at that PC. What are the specs?
There's a 1080 inside that for ordering stuff? Why do businesses get all the tax rebates? Why
can't I like an average show? I was in the snowys earlier and I came over here when your stream
started because I haven't seen a second of a velar stream before today. Oh, no. Oh, no. You picked
the worst. Don't start with me. Start with anyone else in velar. I'm the worst fucking choice to start
your velar experience with because I'm wildly inappropriate at all times. Are you squinting
me right now? Wildly inappropriate at all times. Since you seemed so excited about the property
of reeflings part, maybe the caller can say that and the bowl has your name so you know it's your
bowl that we let you use when you're hungry for ink. Either way, it's about what gets you going more.
I think, why is it 55 bucks for that? Better be a big moneymaker. I think we're gonna get both.
You're super wholesome. Oh, yeah. I'm the one of the few Americans who can understand the Scottish
accent. Like, I'm very lucky that you guys can understand it, but I do confess you're not gonna
like this part reefling. I purposefully annunciate more. I'm sorry. I do. It's just a tooth. Oh,
shit. I hate when I do that honestly. Are you squinting me right now? Oh, that was a lot of product.
Do you sell puppy tails? I need the plug type in three different training sizes. My cuttlefish
puppy girl is getting uppity and needs some correction via banal training.
Okay, I may actually be buying that soon as well. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I think I'm going to be
buying that soon. I need a new one. Okay, I need a new one. Thank you Anonymous for the tip and
thank you Zarian as well. I might be getting that product. All right, I didn't want to be outrageous,
but I kind of want to show you guys all the things I want to buy in like a week's time,
but it's going to be really bad. Like, it's going to be really fucking bad. Excuse me, Ms.
where do you keep the cucumbers and the lube? Why you ask for no reason? I'm sure. Hold on,
Anonymous. I'm sure I've seen that meme that is like by bomb bombs, by a cucumber and by lube and
then look the cashier dead in the eyes while you do it. Are you squinting me right now? For no particular
reason. Does this mean Stronny will be getting a tail soon? To go with the collar, we need to make
sure the collar is nice and tight around her neck so you can always feel like reeflings are
gripping your throat and telling you to behave. Are you squinting me right now? I'm trying to do
my job here, not get away. What the fuck's going on? Hi, Stronny just wanted to let you know I walk
my dog every day, but it makes me sad because I wish it was in his tent. Oh my god. I'm going to need
a slippery caution, slippery one wet sign on the floor in a minute. What the fuck? We're not getting
sued, okay? We're not getting sued because someone had a little fumble. I'm not having it. Whoa, what
did I just give you? Ten bucks? Okay, that was really lucky. I still don't know how to retract
the money. I've yet to figure it out. Stronny, if you put them on throne, would be happy to buy it
for you? Oh, I don't know. I find it so hard to accept gifts like that. I don't know.
Like, I don't mind buying it. Am I weird for considering you're fairly normal and wholesome?
I mean, for the most part, you know, we've been chaining, don't you mind? I don't think, um,
flower is too expensive. I'm so sorry. My flower does not reflect today's prices. No, it does not
get aim. Two dollars for the flower. I apologize, my good sir. All yours, no change. Thank you for
your exact card. Yes, 19 dollars. Awesome degeneracy is what my wife and I call it,
honestly. Stronny with a short color refill. Well, I have a short color stream coming up
very quickly. So basically, there's going to be multiple streams for a little while.
So don't be surprised if some of them are outrageous. I'm literally going to have to explain
to my dad that I'm doing a ring fit stream. So whatever he overhears, if he is awake, he is to
ignore because I'm going to be like a bus of ass. I have not exercised since debut. No, I am not
exaggerating. Bro, I'm getting you stuck in, man. Give me a chance to have some freaking stock. Right,
we need more stock of something. I don't know what yet. Cheese, milk, dark roast coffee is how
right. We'll get eggs as well. We've not had eggs. I'm getting a variety. I promise I'm getting
a variety. I promise. This puppy cuttlefish is going to need a muzzle to keep her quiet when
reeflings breed her like a bitch in heat. I'm at my job and you're in my earpiece telling me these
kinds of things. How am I supposed to look these customers in the eye and say have a good day?
I am trembling. I am quaking at this till right now. I'm trying my hardest to focus.
I am trying my hardest to focus and I'm quaking right now. It must be placed in a fridge. Okay,
that's fine. Oh my god, that is so sad. Pop that there because I want to make sure,
I want to make sure, okay. Mummy, now you know how all the reeflings who listen to you at work
still, it's still my favorite thing. Sorry, I'm making an audio for it. I don't care. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I don't care. I need to make an audio for it. I need you. I have a matey.
Don't buy the coffee. I've not set the price. Nine dollars. That's a big profit. Three dollars
per unit sold. I'm doing it right now. Whoa, this is our biggest freaking thing ever. Thank you.
Thirty two dollars. The pleasure is all mine. I assure you the pleasure is all mine. Why is
of course. Cheeky dollar change. All yours sir. Thank you. Thank you. Whoa. Okay, let's get that
light on. I can already see it getting dark. Don't think I don't know your games. Not again.
Why are they struggling? Are you squiddin' me right now? With a pathing. What's the problem? The next
day, still no cheese. No, no, no, no. Cheese, cheese, cheese, cheese. Okay, cheese, cheese, cheese. Boom.
Cheese is in the cart. Cheese, cheese is in the front door. Freeze, cheese is in the front door.
Oh my God, what are you talking about? I have no idea. Customer Greg, I have absolutely no idea what
you're talking about, my good sir. Look at that. You even have two shelves of cheese. Your claims
of not having cheese, unfounded customer Greg. How dare you? Completely unfounded. I have absolutely
no, your accusations against my store. I ask you instantly to remove your one-star review and a
trip advisor to my freaking supermarket. It is unfounded and it is damaging the sales
and my profit margins. Change, no change, exact change. Thank you, good sir. Couldn't find the
cereal. Yeah, you're right. You can't find the cereal. You want to know why? Because there's
none in stock. Boom. What are you talking about? What are you talking about? I don't know what you
mean. Thank you, customer Greg. And thank you Anonymous for all the tips. You guys are playing
with fire because the efficiency of the gameplay is about to severely go down if you keep this up.
Okay, card. Yes, $19. Thank you, good sir. All yours. Oh, thank you for your costume. No,
appreciate it. Your change. $50, $20. Go. Thank you. Thank you. No, thank you. Cheese. Yes,
cheese. Take the cheese. There's customer Greg right there in the making. There he is. He's
picking up some products. Oh, there you go. There's your cheese. Yep. Thank you. Please remove
that terrible review you left on the supermarket. Would appreciate it. I'm going to start slacking
off at work. Slacking off. Oh my God, that should be the name of the title. Slacking off with your
co-worker at work. Oh my God. I love it. Don't worry about being late, you goofy goober. You have
a sheebie ace of art to look forward to. Be kind, reeflings. Over exposure to work times,
mud can lead to premature ink ejaculation. It's a serious issue and affects one in every five
cephalopods. Are you squiddin' Maria? It's okay, my little cephalopods, I believe you. I can imagine
Strani as a puppy girl. I mean she has the tongue belicking, of course. And she did tell us yesterday
that her cervix is good for doggy. Stop! If you don't use juice, cetentical bone, you are gonna
have to bake like a good puppy. Are you squiddin' me right now? Stop! Strani, you are a good girl.
Stop! But don't worry, even if you misbehave, we'll still take you on walkies. You'll just have
to be muzzled, blindfolded, and have an egg vibing in the clam for correction purposes.
I am interested. You can't be saying the stuff in my head, peas. We're getting explicit 50
nine. I can't focus on the numbers, Mason! Me next. Thank you anonymous and reluctantly seen.
Stop it! You're making me embarrased. God, you guys are really having... Why is it only women
have problem with the shelf? I'm starting to think something's going on here. What are the odds that
both women are known for window shopping and they can't decide on what product to buy at the stage?
Stop. How is this on YouTube? Why? We're in a supermarket. What are you all about?
We're in a supermarket. Excuse me, miss, you seem to have a wet patch. It is in aisle one,
it had an odd taste to it, and also it smells like clowns. No! Strani, I think we need to get a
clicker to help you stay motivated while working and be a good girl. No! Stop it! Thank you,
anonymous and rent desolation. Stop! Right, I didn't focus. You're getting redirected into
Sheebie's ASMR anyway, so she gonna keep you going. Right, I'm sorry but what is going on here?
Seriously, three of you make up your mind. Your husbands are at home wondering where you are
and you're just going nuts over the oil. There must be something wrong with the shelf.
I don't know. Can I push it forward? Carry? Okay. I'm just gonna move it forward.
No, it didn't make them adjust. Huh. What? What's wrong with the pathing? I don't see it.
It must be the product then. Hmm. User confusing me, ladies. I don't know what's the matter.
I'm afraid I don't know what the matter is. Right, I'm gonna try and sell out of my product to buy
the next upgrade to expand the shop. They're bugging. Yeah. They're bugging? I don't know what's going
on with them. Oh crap, we have bills to pay. Oh, come on. We're like all the way down again.
This game is actually hard. Sorry, I said it. Last time you bought Flour, it fixed.
Are they wanting Flour? Is that why everyone's having a hard time? I'm gonna try and sell out
my product so I can expand the store. If everyone buys everything that I've got right now, then boom,
we can do the next objective. We will never make money at this rate. Typical Scottish corner
shop, actually, though. Our money. That game literally made the game wants us to take along
because we don't do that here. No, we don't borrow from the banks. We blow them up. Stop.
Refling. You can't say that out loud. But you were thinking it. All right, hydration check,
refling. You need hydrate.
Honestly, the begging girlfriend ASMR made you laugh your ass off. I'm glad you enjoyed it.
It was so fun to come up with. I came up with everyone's meme ASMR ideas,
but I didn't want to risk anyone's channel. I came up with that idea myself and I was like,
okay, I'll risk my channel by saying something silly like that. It popped off. It might hit 100K,
which is insane. It's insane to say your first uploaded ASMR video might get 100K views.
That's insane. I actually think we're gonna be... Oh, thank you for all your...
Your... Yes, thank you, custom. Thank you. Love you.
The gamble has played off, honestly.
You did this to yourself, Strone. I remember you once challenging reflings that if they wanted
to dominate you, they'd have to do a lot better. Now we have finally found your weakness, Puppy
No!
No, no, no, no. I literally just got tingles. Like, my body literally reacted to that. What the
fuck? No! Thank you, anonymous, but no! Stop. I'm trying to freaking run a supermarket.
Le supermarch. J'ai travaill. Le supermarch, mes yeux. Non jou dans la
travailler. I'm fucking trying so hard to say stuff in French. Bro, right, relax. I don't
know what's going on. We're gonna need to move it. Can you guys let me put it down before you
come over and glitch out again? How do I take the stuff off the shelf? It's messing up my game.
How do I take the stuff off the shelf? Okay, you know how I said the game's polished? I take
it back. I take it back. The game's not polished. The women are stuck again. I'm trying. I'm trying.
I'm trying. I think the game needs a little bit more work, but overall, we're getting there.
There's definitely something glitched out on that shelf. I'm gonna see if I can take the
stuff off it, like the products off of it, maybe. I don't really know what the issue is.
$24! All yours, sir. Thank you. We need $350 before the end of the day. And because you
are all being assigned here, I think we're getting less customers as well,
because the game can't assign too many customers at work. She's hypnotizing that.
They're baffled by the low prices. They can't comprehend.
I think you need an empty box to remove stuff. Right, okay, let's grab a box. We'll just buy
whatever. It's on cheap. Right, bread. Let's go. Purchase. Let's go. And then... No! Just wait a second,
please. Close through, drop, take. Are you squiddin' me right now? The box doesn't match the size,
are you jokin'? I bet you all it would take is a surprise slap to her arse or an extreme shock
to her collar. And she would be whimpering and panting and drooling at the mouth for her eflings.
I must have them hypno eyes rolling in the back of your head ahead of our style.
What am I even s-
What do I even see?
What was I supposed to see? Thank you, Rufeland, for the tips.
And on to the mid-today, clearly. I thought I'm the one that's supposed to be coming up with
the scenarios, not you. Right, oil. Buy it and then get fricking rid of it off the dang shelves.
Okay, yes, yes, yes, thank you. Thank you, Ruf. So got another week.
Man, I'm sick of this TTS spam. I want to watch a Stranny Cutler stream, not Brian's, each.
Are you had enough of Brian? Brian! Right, Brian, that's enough out of you, young man. Do you-
Did I make myself clear? Brian, no more. Okay. All right, as Brian dealt with, don't worry,
I got you, Rufeland. Right, you, all. How do I put it in? Take. See you all glitching out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And they all- Right, I'm leaving this
box here in case it's glitchy, because what the heck was all that about, honestly? Oh, it's getting
dark in the shop. Ah, it's getting dark. I'm scared of the dark unironically. Are you squidding me
right now? This place is too small and crowded. Two stars. Are you helping me? Are you- Wait,
are you helping me gameplay-wise via role-playing as a customer?
Are you helping me gameplay-wise role-playing as a customer? I think you are, because we do need
to expand. We just need the 350. Thank you, customer Greg's- Wait, what? There's no way.
There's actually no way. I'm $1 short from expanding. This is meta. This is why I like
backseat gaming. That is so creative. That is so creative. I can even do that myself. Oh my gosh,
right. Management, growth, section two. Purchase this section to expand. There we go, we did it.
Oh my gosh, that is hilarious. Thank you, customer Greg's fucking way to dollars change,
ma'am. Thank you. Couldn't find- No, you're not going to find nothing in this shop.
Look at it. Oh my god, our scene got upgraded. It's getting so big. Yay. Okay, I need to push
the products back on the shelf. This is not backseat and you are in a video game. No, because
some features don't like it when you tell them what to do and I'm like, please help me so much.
Thank you again for the tip. That was so creative. Customer Greg's wave, that's hilarious.
Honestly, hilarious. Right, we're going to push some stuff back. We need to- I wonder if you can
buy the supermarket radio. Right, all the frozen products are going to go along this- well,
or cold products, I guess. I'm going to keep the boxes in case something glitches out again,
because that was a bit of a nightmare to fix. Nice, it's not an average customer shop anymore.
It's not. Look how big the windows are as well. We are up. We- oh my god, sorry. Can I just say
the serotonin boost of like physically seeing your shop getting bigger because all of your
hard work paid off? I love these kind of games. Oh my god. I love these kind of games. I said it.
I said it. I'm sorry. I don't care. I said it. Right, what's the next objective? Oh, we haven't
been assigned one. Right, what are the bills? I'll pay the seven dollars. I can't pay rent.
Stronny be a good girl. Roll onto your back and I will give you a some tummy rubs. Then if you
keep being good, maybe I will give you this bone. No! You called yourself Stronny's trainer!
Reef- wait, we only have oil. Reef-ling! You can't- oh, maybe that could be a nickname for you guys.
You can be my personal trainer.
Could we get away with that? Could we? Should we? I don't know. Right, if I bought one of everything,
how much is that? Are you squidy? We can do 200 bucks. Remember, Stronny, if you want something,
you are going to have to bark for it. A good girl likes you knows that you can't speak English.
Years are done. Years are done. No more. Anonymous. Thank you. Me no, thank you.
Hey, I'm far in the back of this seat. Maybe keep a box for each product in the
storage for any more glitch shelves? Good girl. Okay. What is this? Is this a break room?
Are you squidin' me right now? Is this a break room? I got a bowl with her name on it so she can
shlop. Shlop oman na ala corn on the cup. This should give me hate. I only have oil to sell.
This is literally an American supermarket now. America kanya! TTS was a mistake. Stop! Thank you,
Tharia. IBW. Anonymous. Are you squidin' me right now? Knock, knock, mom, are you okay? Why are you
salivating in front of your monitor? This puppy salivating. Okay, everyone is buying oil.
Literally. Yeah, I know you can't find nothing. I ain't got no stock. Everyone please purchase the
oil at your next convenience, okay? Because we are running low on the market prices lower than
three bucks. Okay, hopefully it changes as well. Oh my god, I think we're gonna have to like...
Oh, there's a customer. You spawned out of nowhere. You were not even in my shop a moment ago.
Please. Okay, everyone. Okay, yes, just buy oil. Thank you. This is helping so much. I'm not even
kidding. Please continue to buy oil. Does someone say oil's American screeching?
I have a really funny clip of Azura, actually. Thank you Momo for the tip as well. I have actually
a really funny clip of Azura. I might send it to her and see if she will let me post it.
It was us before we did the group collab on debut. She randomly starts singing the American
national anthem, but Azura's got some lungs on her. She's like,
and I'm like in the background. I'm like, make check, make check, and she's like,
I'm like, Amy, Amy, make check, make check, just so we can hear you. It was really funny,
so I'm gonna see if she's happy with me post it because it was hilarious. I'm like being super
serious. Like, oh, that was good guys, right? Make check, mercy, make check, check, check,
and then buy the drones early night. It was absolutely hilarious. So, okay, I'm gonna have to
buy some product. That isn't like a squadillion dollars because, right, 64 bucks. Yeah, just,
yeah, one oil. Yep. I know you can't find anything, sir. You're gonna, you'll never guess why because
we don't have anything in stock. I'm working on it. I'm working on it. We need an American flag
bikini cookout, Azura. I think that is a fantastic alternative outfit for Azura. I actually fully
agree with that. I'm not even kidding. I actually fully agree. I want to see those bedonkers bedonking
in an American bikini outfit. I'll take it. You can sing pretty damn well too though.
Well, I got Emmy, we finally got Emmy's song cover, which I've not paid the guy for yet.
Actually, sorry, if you're watching right now, I will pay you after the stream,
and I just need some time to nap after the stream, and then I will deal with the rest.
Gonna grill them dogs, honestly though. Are you squidding me right now?
Just thinking about how a strong themed Tenga would go hard, and so would I.
What's a Tenga? Oh, that's the wrong number. Thank you, Tharia, for the tip, or the super
trot. I don't know if I have to say super trot tip. I don't know. It's the same thing. What's a Tenga?
It sounds like a Konga. Konga, Konga, Konga, Konga. Tenga, Tenga, Tenga.
Tenga is an honor hall. Oh, I've been singing about it.
I've been singing about it.
Okay, then. That's what it's called. I've never heard that terminology.
Oh, you've just absolutely messed me up. Give me that back, and then put it down there.
She's a degeneracy built into her blood. No, why did I buy more oil? We have more than enough oil.
I'm gonna have to hire a reflin to go on the checkout, because this is getting tricky.
This is getting tricky. Insufficient change. Oh, what?
Giving six bucks. Okay, make it four, and then do 120, then one. Jeez.
Sorry, sir. I can't count, but thank you for giving me the patience to count. Kind of blue.
Come on, I need to restock here. Stop buying stuff. Give me a freaking moment to breathe. No
change. Thank you. Change two dollars. Thank you. Please, I need to like quickly buy stuff like
right now, because everything is so empty. I'm literally just buying anything.
Please. I don't know. Bread? I've not had bread in a while. Go. Boom. We love bread.
Shadow Wizard Money Gang. We love bread around these parts. She's an oil. Change. Oh my God.
Sorry. I love this game. I'm addicted. I'm not gonna lie. I think I could easily play 12 hours of
this. I'm not sure anyone wants to actually sit and watch 12 hours of this.
I didn't take this phone like the good girl you are. Reflex where I played Supermarket Simulator.
I didn't know the flubber aisle really got you going. Hey, Stronny, if you are a puppy girl,
what breed would you want to be? I haven't thought that far ahead. I don't know.
I have black hair, so this is an interesting TTS room. Literally, I'm like, is the bakery aisle
really getting you going that good? I mean, shit. I'll take it. I'm glad that you guys are enjoying
it. Thank you so much. Stronny's trainer and anonymous. I am working on the stock issues,
man. Please have patience for the love of God. I just get paid minimum wage. I just show up and
I'm trying. I'm actually getting stressed by my virtual job. I can't believe it. I can't handle
stress. Oh, God, the packages, please. Will someone please think of the packages? Milk is only two
dollars? What? I'm coming, please. Wait. I was gonna say three dollars seems a bit more,
a bit more economy related. Oh my God. I'm actually getting stressed. I can't keep up.
Actually, unironically, can't keep up. Oh my God. I need help. I need help. I need an adult.
I need an adult. Wait. I'm the adult. No. I don't have time for all of this. Right. We've got sugar
again. That's good. That's good. That's good. That's good. That's good. All right. All right. All
right. All right. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. I can do this. I can do this. Ninety. Why would you
give me such big number of change? The milk is French. Wait, is it? Does it say delay on it?
Does the milk say delay? Milk semi-skilled. Boulay. What? It is French. Well, zero isn't French.
Okay. We're gonna unpack everything that we purchased. I have no idea what we purchased.
I was just busy panicking, but okay. Not to ruin it. Right. Close your ear canal if you don't want
to hear a spoiler on what one of the zero shorts are. She played supermarket simulator and one of
the things she said was like, do you want my milk basically? Because she was selling milk product.
But it was like such a good clip and it's getting made and I'm so excited for it to come out.
A British woman selling French product. Disgusting, honestly. What will they think?
Is there a Boulay? No. Don't call her that. I'm just kidding me right now.
If it starts raining, I think I know what to do with all that oils. Omega.
Wait, what does that mean? Azu Ryuji. Oh, come on. You need to make your names easier for me to say.
What is that? Azu Re Ya Uji. Thank you for, thank you for letting me take your cherry yonk.
My cherry now. What are you gonna do about it? Yonkers. My super chat cherry now.
I'm fucking it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Fond de la bosom. Well, you should have heard of one of
the names. Right, I can tell you later but I can't tell you right now. Cover myself in oil?
What? If it starts raining, I think I know what to do with all that oil. I'm to cover myself in oil?
Hard-ass names, honestly. Oil up. Stronnycuddles oiled up when? Right now. I technically already
made that ASMR but I got taken down but I'm gonna put it back up on September because it wasn't
the clapping that got the video taken down. It was the breathing in the ear. Yes, that is true.
How much is cheese? Cheese is three bucks. How much is pasta? Pasta is three dollars.
How much is bread? Bread, I am overcharging for bread. Very big. Very big overcharge? No, I will
not say why. Right, tea. I made a good profit from, we've not got, I think we need another fridge.
You know that. Oh, there's a thing as a double fridge. Oh, I mean, where are the floors? Oh,
we can change the floor? I mean, I'm not really fussed for changing the floor. I'm not sure that's
gonna make a difference to sales, is it? Unless the carpet is like absolutely minging, I think we're
okay just to leave the carpet as it is. Right, pay my bills, pay my rent. I can't pay rent. Hiring,
right, what's going cashier? One, automated checkout, daily wage, 80 bucks, hiring cost,
100, complete checkout. What? Complete checkout, it requires store level 10. I can't hire you
refling until store level 10? It's an old troll science comic. Oil floats on water. So to fly,
you cover yourself in oil, wait for it to rain, then you can fly for free.
What? How was I supposed to get that reference? Thank you, tiny spiny. There's no way. Hire a
reef stalker. Oh, that's actually pretty good. I'll take that. Please understand that algorithm is
unfamiliar and uncomfortable with the concept of breathing. Literally, though. Pass the three
bucks outrageous, honestly. How? Right, so I can't hire anyone yet. That's fine. Storage, I don't want
customization. Oh, I can change the name by cost, money. Change entrance. No, thank you. I'll take
my tight clamp and elsewhere. Growth, right. Section three, four. So this is for the sigh. How much?
How can I make this much profit selling eggs? How big can this game get? Product license. Peanut
butter, flour. Oh my, this game is like way bigger than I first imagined. Banknot, market,
furniture, a new shelf maybe? How much is a shelf? 100 bucks?
Maybe a shelf for more, although the... Oh!
A checkout. Right, a checkout means we can hire a reflin at level 10. Okay. Okay, let's just focus
on getting our money up. Okay, we can do that. Clamps to take, you need industrial pliers.
Stronny, your bakery always gets me going. I will eat all of your cake. Once I am done,
all that will be left is some cream. Are you... Are you fucking naming Stronny's cake on us, sir?
That's amazing. Thank you for the tip. The bakery, the bakery's not open. All we have is sugar. We
don't even have flour. I'm out of flour already, literally. No, even started and I'm out of products.
Where's flour? Go. Order. Oh no, there's something else in here. $60. Let's just get the
flour in. Let's just get it in. Okay, a yolk now. Hee hee hee. Oh, I do have flour. Right,
I'm just blind. I'm sorry I'm blind. Don't look at me. Don't look at me. Okay, I'm blind.
Grilla's out of cake. Stronny provides the egg for the bakery. Did you know you spawn in
with like 10,000 eggs and literally only like 100 or viable or something silly like that?
There's like some, honestly, I could talk about like pregnancy and ovulation cycle and all that.
Speaking of ovulation, thank you very much for your custom goods, sir. Oh no, the conversation I'm
having in the headset, it's just with my co-workers. They're locked in the room right now in the staff
room. I just don't have access to my co-workers yet. It's fine. No, no, don't report me for the
conversations. I know you can't find the cereal. I can't afford the cereal. That's why you can't
find it, sir. Okay, I can afford it this time. Okay, you just spend your time at the shelves
a lot, but no, no, no, don't go to the- thank you. They're so quick. Like, they honestly didn't
give you like, I'm sorry, but you can actually see me restocking and trying to do all these
jobs at the same time. And they're like, servicing now, please. I don't know your marks. I'd be
too shy to say anything though. I don't know if that's the component, but like, you have no filter,
by the way. I know I'm aware. I'm sorry. I apologize. How do we restock your eggs? No, you
spawn in with them. You spawn in with all the eggs. You don't generate any new eggs at birth or
anything like that, like after birth or anything. You spawn in like that for genetic material. It's
actually really fascinating. I don't know. I don't know how you felt about the education stream
yesterday. I had a blast, okay? I'm gonna be honest. I had a blast. Sorry, I like education. I think
it's fun. And I didn't know if you guys knew I was gonna give you a little quiz at the end,
but I was like giggling away, kicking my feet under the table when I was making my wee thing up
for years. I was like, I'm gonna get him. This is how I'm gonna get him. I'm gonna do this. I'm gonna
do that. Are you squeezing me right now? And I'll do that. I bet Stronny would love a refling
growling in her, like a predator ready to turn her into prey. Little pup will learn her place
under her alpha refling. What? The list, how wet is the fabric of your chair from this teasing?
Stop! I'm in the supermarket! Les supermarchs! Arrte! Arrte! J'attends la fucking supermarch,
man. Fucking hell, reflins. Why are we all, why are we so, what happened? What, is it filming?
Why are we all so revved up? Give us a week. Give us a week. Give us a week, okay? A week and then
it all starts up again, okay? Because we, something's going on with us right now. It is a film.
It's a full moon, clearly, because what's going on? No, I'm just purchasing stuff. Please,
give me a sec. I swear the game makes them teleport as soon as you look away for a millisecond.
Out my way, ma'am. You're in my way. Right, coffee. Oh my god, that's so satisfying the way
they stalk. Oh, I just walked into them. Okay, small age happy break. If us
reflings were to work in your store, what type of uniform would we have? Just the hat or would
we have a little shirt as well? Would you have a shirt? I don't think I'm a uniform. That's a
good question. I need an easy access uniform. I said what I said. I don't care. I'm sorry. I said
what I said. I need an easy access. That's it. That is how I will deal with the nine to five.
Most people need alcohol at the end of the day to deal with their nine to five.
Some people need smoke cigarettes for the nicotine hit. Some people, you know,
recreational drugs to deal with the nine to five at the end of the day. I just need easy access.
That's all I'm asking. Velcro? Velcro? That would be hilarious. I'm sorry. That's absolutely
hilarious. Velcro all constantly like every 10 minutes, all you hear is and then in the break
room, just every two seconds. That's honestly hilarious. I let you weren't you were not even
approaching this till I swear you were not even approaching this. There's no way and it's getting
No, stop. I'm just turning the lights on, please. Turn the lights on. Why is there so many
customers? Apologies, Mamalaz-Riflin saw a cute supermarket worker working the cash register
and we couldn't resist. See her blush. Stop. Okay, that was a compliment. So I'll take it.
Why is there so many customers? What's going on? Don't you all have like wife and kids to go home to
juice? What do you mean you're getting milk to go home? Thank you Anonymous for all the tips.
You're all called anonymous, but I don't want to grip you together. I will thank you individually.
Thank you Anonymous. Thank you Anonymous. Thank you Anonymous. I'm under the counter.
It's raining some strange liquid and I'm hearing some wild shite.
You're not hearing anything. This place is empty. Needs more items. Three stars. Okay. Okay. Okay.
We're getting up. There we're getting up. Wait, wait, that's a new, you're making new
YouTube accounts because that's your first super chat registered on the account. There is no way
you're going to all that effort. You're making new YouTube accounts to stream snipe in game.
Thank you customer Gregson. Oh my God. That's amazing. Momo, thank you for the tip as well.
There's strange liquid stuff. Oh my God. How are you going to such efforts?
Right. I'm just going to completely sell out a product. I know I should probably order before.
Order. Have you guys been on TikTok to that Scottish Chinese shop? I'm so sorry to
completely derail with brain rot. So on TikTok, there's this Chinese Scottish shop
and she like packs the orders, but she's got a funny accent. So she goes, come pack this customer's
order with me. This family needs 100% discount and some special treatment.
Yeah. Oh, thank you. This family needs 100% discount honestly though. Order. Yes,
fucking sin sister knows what it is. It's Becca's takeaway. And she's like, come with me today to
pack this customer's order, but it's like a vocal fry on order. So it's like order.
Because it's not really that common to have a vocal fry in Scotland. It's rather,
it's very Americanized if you will. Oh my God. Don't talk about America Challenge failed yet
again. Honestly, I can't believe it. Right. What have we got? I definitely need in a much bigger
fridge. I'm needing a bigger refrigerator. Right. We are going to preemptively pay all of our rent
issues. I don't feel like I'm making any profit. Am I going crazy? But I feel like I'm like losing
money somehow. Like I'm struggling to pay these bills. Me and Strone are going to do an
really Scottish tourist stream and we're going to go to a mukbang at Becca's. But I'm packing this
order for two v-chippers. Would you guys still love me if I had a vocal fry?
Okay. Wait. How can I do a vocal fry on a Scottish accent? Order. Good afternoon, Henry
Flings. I hope you're doing well. I could not maintain that. That's hideous. Right. Let's buy
the big wall of ours. What have we got? $200? Oh, we're doing math with my order. Oh my God.
That's awful. Please do not speak for the rest of the stream. I'm sorry. Thank you. Are you
squiddin' me right now? Wow. At this point, forget the ASMR booth. Just open a store staffed by
Reeflings. Okay. You can stay in the break room and be in charge of Team morale. We may be hard,
but you can take it. No need to be a good girl. You can be our bad girl. Wait, but would that
actually boost morale? Like, unironically, you know how like businesses are all like, I'm trying to
boost the morale of the staff without increasing their wages or whatever. I'm like, I feel like
that might work. You know, just me sitting in the staff room being like, how are the sales good?
And then pop, pop, pop, pop, pop. This is the most inappropriate conduct a store has ever.
I think business would be booming though, you know? And like, as like, as a customer,
you come in and then like, all you hear is like muffled like, like behind the door is like,
is everything okay back there? It's just like, yeah, we're just expanding the shop. We're drilling.
We need to drill holes in the walls. So that's what that noise is.
Thank you, Zarian, for the tip. I think I've seen that video on a certain way. So,
Chinese, Scottish, YUMMY. I miss a Chinese. Right. I'm going to buy all the products tomorrow
and I'm going to go crazy and stack all the motherfucking jobs. Products found expensive,
products not found. Right, relax. Right, we can't all fricking, right. I know the market price is
changing. I'm sorry, but I ain't got time. Okay. Order. Oh, you can-
I mean, you're not wrong. You're not, I didn't realize you can run in this game.
Oh my gosh. How long have I been on this game for? And I didn't know you could fricking run.
Look how fast I am. Are you serious? You can run in this game the whole time? I am so fast.
I am so fast. Is this a joke? Oh, I can't sell the egg. Sorry.
Right. I am so fricking fat. Oh my god. Wait, why did I buy so many fridge stuff? I don't have room
in the fridge. Everyone watching the products expire. Oh my gosh. I didn't know you could move in this-
Oh, open, open. I was wondering why the customers aren't coming. Wait, how do I clean the outside
of the shop? It's dirty. Oh my god. This is not, this is not raising my beleveliness.
Oh, whatever that word is in Japan, beleveniminess. Oh, if we're going to say
belevenus, that's the word belevolne. What is that word?
Your belevolence. Your belevolence? Benevolence. Okay. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Right.
Change 30 bucks. Go. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm working on the oil. Okay. I'll order oil, jeez.
I'm trying. I'm trying. Okay. I have time. I have time because I can run.
Bruh. Why did I not figure out you could run? Can you crouch? No, you can't crouch. Are you
squiddin' me right now? Okay, you can't crouch. It's fine. It's fine. No, don't bug out.
I feel out of place here as a sub. You're allowed to be a sub.
I'm pretty, I'm pretty alright. I mean, if you've listened to the new Patreon audio,
ain't no way you're a, you're a dumb in that audio. Look at the state of this place.
Riefland should be picking up the boxes. I'm going back to Tescos, honestly. Benevolence. Benevolence.
Okay, that sounds right. That sounds correct. I wish, I'm going to have to order, order
freakin' tea so I can put these away again. I don't know. There seems to be something about
the bottom, like, left or, I don't know. Sliced bread is too expensive.
Okay, I agree with you. I'm sorry. I agree. I do agree. I agree. I agree. I'm sorry.
Look, the prices change every day. Isn't it funny how the prices change every day,
but they continue to go up and they never go down, even though there might be moments in time
where things aren't as expensive as they should be. Isn't that curious? Curious, curious. Yeah,
that's what I think about you. Right, bread. We need more bread. Bread, bread, bread, bread.
Oh my God, fast. I'm fast as fuck, boy. Oh my God, sorry. This is so sad. It's fine to re-stock as
well. I'm so fast. I'm so fast. Oh my God. Oh my God, I'm so fast. Sorry. This is the most
efficient shop. Sorry. Sorry. I need to unlock that break room, like, right now because the
reflins are waiting on my thoughts. Either the reflins are waiting on me or I'm waiting on them.
You know how it is around these parts, baby. Oh, I need the coffee box and tea box. Are you
squidding me right now? I need the tea. Give me the tea. No wonder Dad doesn't come here. There are
no items. No, no, there is. There is. I'm waiting for people to freaking buy this. Are you squidding
me right now? There's milk and water, but no one's buying. ASMR, Scottish Cuttlefish Attempts
to Learn Her Second Language, English. Stop! It's true. It's actually true. No, it's true. It's
true. Thank you, tiny Spanish. That's actually so true. Customer Greg's daughter. I'm working on it,
daughter. I'm working. Customer Greg's daughter. I'm sorry. Forgive me. I need to fix the glitch
that's going on right now. I can't believe reflins are about to turn Strani into a free-use public
owner. Hold. I don't think we can say that. Can we say that out loud? I don't know.
Greg got a nuclear family. Literally, Greg is winning at life. Right, put all of this shit in
the box. Stop. Whatever it, stop. Literally, stop. Whatever you guys are doing, knock it off. I'm
getting fed up. I'm getting, I'm not putting anything bottom right because it seems to be some sort of
weird glitch. $12. Thank you, ma'am. Are you squidding me right now? I apologize for my remarks.
I was getting frustrated that none of... Bark, bark. Growl. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Now that add-on is being the Doug Customer Greg's daughter's dog. Are we role-playing as a
meta role-play as I'm getting advice to play this game? This is, this is getting insane.
It's just getting insane. This is amazing. Oh my god, look at the money rolling in now.
Oh, I need to hire, refland. I need to hire you so badly to get on the till. This is like,
it's never ending. It's never ending. There's so many of you. What's going on? Why? Because I fixed
the glitch, I think. Boom. Right, we've have $150. Can people start buying from the fridge?
My products are going to go, they're going to spoil. I'm not even kidding. I need a new fridge.
It's better to buy the 375. I don't have 375 though.
Thank you, Anonymous. I can't believe reliefans are about to turn strong in there for you.
Ah, no, I'm not reading that out loud. Stop it, Anon. Bad Anon. Spank.
Tell me when Shibi goes live, by the way, just because she's doing ASMR today.
And Shibi is so close to 10k and I'm so excited. I'm about to...
I'm so excited for my genmei's success. Please give love and support to my genmeis.
I'm so proud of them and they're so hardworking and I love them and I'm going to kiss them on the
mouth. Anyway, that's just me. Shibi's live. Oh, I think her supermarket enterprises might be over
with. I don't know. I'm going to record that. My dad guessed in each of her names shortly.
Right, I'll play another day. I'm totally not addicted to this game, by the way.
But yes, my dad is going home in like a week's time, so I'm going to be depressed. But the
good news is there's going to be tons of streams. But deep down, I'm going to be sad inside.
But you cheer me up. And I get to play loads of games with you again and I get to do all the
ridiculous plans again. And I get to record all the ASMRs because I have tons of people waiting
on me to do collab ASMRs. So there's going to be content out there. But the only exchanges that
my dad has to go on. But that's okay because that's how life works sometimes. Okay, let's
very quickly buy new stock. Can I very quickly do this? Stock, you, you just shove everything in.
Literally shove everything in. Are you squiddin' me right now? Please.
I think we're going to get in trouble. You guys are going to have to start substituting the way I
do. You guys are going to have to start substituting because I'm getting, stop buying milk! Oh my gosh,
stop buying milk. Stop buying refrigerated products. Please, I'm begging. Please, brain,
stop messing up so badly. Right, you. Right, you guys are going to need to start substituting
because I'm getting nervous for this board now. I'm getting nervous. I'm getting nervous,
but I'm glad you enjoyed the boot although. Because not everyone does it. Some people are like,
oh my god, I hate it. I hate it. It's like, bruh, bruh! Let's just role play. Close your eyes. It's
not real. Close your ears. Close your ears. You're subjecting yourself to something you don't like.
Close your ears. Honestly, my dad literally listened to this conversation being like,
what the fuck is going on in that room? What do you mean I have product? No! You're not supposed
to do that. I'm glad you went flower all yours. And you gave me a perfect change. Thank you, sir.
Have a good night. Have a good evening. I appreciate you. Can I please? Why are people not buying?
I mean.
Strongly, I will gift so many memberships if one day you can do an alternative outfit of you as
a puppy girl. I'm begging you. I don't, I mean, so my donathon is coming up. I've said like,
my donathons more like group activity stuff or like free access stuff. I've got about free use
on my mind now. Like, accessible stuff. You don't have to pay to access it. If you guys wanted to
like, I'm not going to stop you from like picking out because Azura is going to pick out what she
wants to do for her donathon. I assume she's going to do the same thing she needs next after.
Strongly cut us oiled up in 4K is currently the search suggestion. Thank you so much for letting
me yank your boy chair. Wait, what? Did I not yank your boy chair like two minutes ago?
We are good fish, believe us, maybe. We are good fish. We're the goodest fish in all the land.
We just mind yourself swimming and stuff. Yeah, if you guys want to, as if I'm going to say no
to a fucking alt puppy outfit, if you guys want to, you know, you know, hit me up, dab me up.
Are you joking? I'll be a puppy VTuber. Are you joking? Like, literally, I will get the custom
collar and it literally says property of reefling and then I'll get a toggle and everything and
please don't think I'm not going to do that because I'm a laundry serious. Right.
Okay, let's do this and then pop that down and then let's sell these eggs because they are
literally rotting. Are you squidding me right now? Oh, eggs are only one. Free you zone a hole? No,
she's still in charge, but I'm about to make her into a Twinkie.
Reeflings, right, we're about to get in trouble. We're about, we're unironically about to get
in trouble. Stop it. I'm going to have to spank you, okay? You've been naughty right now. Oh,
hold on, hold on, right, put the cheese in, right, the cheese has probably expired like half a century
ago, but hey ho, and that's not going to stop us. Came back just in time for the pet play,
rip Vod. Honestly, I'm starting to get, I'm getting nervous for the Vod. If we can all
take a deep breath and get ready to be redirected into Sheebie's lovely.
Four dollars for eggs? Sheesh, don't mind if I do. I mean, honestly, this isn't that badly
stopped in all consideration. Right, we'll play one more day and then we're redirected into Sheebie.
No, I'm not addicted. Are you squidding me right now? Hey, are you guys hiring? I have no experience.
Unemployed Greg's grandson. Look, you have to start somewhere with experience. Don't you love it when
places require you to have experience, but they won't hire people who've never had experience
before? Isn't that a fascinating point of them being in a part of this society? Hmm, isn't that
curious that they make it really impossible for you to even get an entry level job without having
a freaking PhD in fucking Yunnan? Honestly, it's getting outrageous. Don't you just love that
part of society in the community at large? Don't you just fucking love it? Literally,
don't you love it? This is getting a bit too real, honestly. Are you squidding me right now?
Might be the cutest Twinkie I've ever seen. You think I'm a cute Twinkie?
Thank you as a Rijie for letting me pop your cherry again. I don't know why YouTube said
let me do it twice, but it did. Anonymous. Bit of strong eats. Oh, not whole. Oh my god. I think
I missed that. Oh, I didn't realize you called yourself that. Thank you, Momo. Thank you, Zion.
Thank you, unemployed Greg's grandson and Momo again. Literally five years experience for an
entry level job, like fucking calm down. Honestly, I could absolutely kick. I was going to say the
C word, but you're not allowed to say the C word. Graduate with a bachelor's degree, and I can't
even get an entry level retail job. Honestly, ma'am, why are you giving me that much change?
Don't do that again. That made myself clear. Don't do that again. Four bucks change. Let me think.
All yours. I'll always just go for the dollar bill. Searching for 10 years experience in a 25-year-old
is a while. Are you squidding me right now? It is. That didn't answer my question. Yes, I will hire
if you don't have experience because I'll teach you everything I can teach you.
Okay, now that's a tall order. Thank you for your custom search. This is our biggest order.
$29 reduced. Thank you. Thank you for your custom. That's our biggest sale yet. I can't believe it.
I can't believe having an array of products leads to people purchasing it multiple versions of it.
Shocking behavior. Honestly, shocking. Absolutely shocking. Good girl, strongy. I knew you could
be a good if you tried. Keep this up and I will give you a treat later. Okay, that's acceptable
because that's implications, but it's not going to get as bad. Yes, I will hire, I will teach you
everything I know, and then you can be, and I'll vouch for your CV. I saw, oh my god, I should get a
throwaway number that you guys can use for a CV, and then they'll phone up and they'll be like,
hey, Anon says that you worked, they worked for you for like a year. Can you tell us about their
experience and all that, and I'll just like straight up like guess you up. I'll be like,
yeah, he was absolutely fantastic. I cannot recommend the employee. I was really sad to see him go,
but unfortunately, because I, you know, I had a few complications with my health, I could no
longer employ him, but Anon's perfect 10 out of 10. I so want to do that. That'd be the funniest
thing ever. Like I'll give you an email. I wonder why Grandpa hates this place. No, Grandpa likes
it. Look, I've got tons of products. Like come on. So I actually, this, I'm doing really well,
so I'm actually doing so well. So I don't believe you. I don't believe you first, I think. I definitely
need like a double fridge though. This is getting like outrageously. Oh, I'm about to be able to afford
a double fridge. Don't mind if I do. Any references? Yeah, I'm the reference. She's such a sweetheart.
I'll get you guys on a job somewhere. I know exactly what they want to hear because,
you know, if you didn't know. Well, now you know, hydration check, refling.
I'm waiting for my application to be approved. I need to be level 10 before I can hire a
refling, unfortunately, Greg. Grigory. I wish I wasn't so scared. I would love to play Fanaf,
but I get very scared. I literally have a heart attack at the concept of the game.
So we shan't be playing Fanaf. But we can definitely watch the Fanaf movie.
Hear me out. Fanaf movie and a karaoke thing. Watch along. And we'll watch. I'll tell you what,
I'll get Emmy to play Fanaf, right? And then I'll watch her play it. And then we'll do the
Fanaf movie and then we'll do Fanaf karaoke. How about that? So I don't have to play it. I don't
have to be. It's just we shit in my panty loons. You know what I'm saying? Change 44. Oh my God,
I'm so smart. What? Oh, wow. Sorry. Business is actually booming. What do you mean a fully
stocked shop equals business booming? Because I can, I literally am so busy now.
Oh, are you squidding me right now? Are we flings? No, you spelled it wrong!
My flings, I missed hearing that.
Violetton, Violetton, the other spelling. We're under the water, Violetton. Violetton,
the other spelling, the other spelling, the other spelling. Honestly, it's genuinely not
a big deal. I literally paid for your concept and created you type thing. Nothing was a sign.
So literally saw his butt. But we spell it ee, r-e-e-fling. Thank you so much,
Violetton, for the 20. And it's nice to see you again. Nice to see you. Nice. Any old
refling, any new refling. Don't worry, you're all equally getting shagged. Shut the fuck up!
Sorry, I'm hyper. I'm really enjoying this game right now. I'm so sorry. I am so sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm enjoying this game thoroughly. It's the game. It's, it's the game. Okay, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. Right, we're gonna order,
I dare, the double fridge, and then we're gonna order some product. I'm sorry. Okay, I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Right, hold on, how do I do that?
Are you squidding me right now? You are? Yeah. Reflings are down bad. Uh-huh. Sorry,
Strani, we've been very bad boys. You have, yeah. Whatever could we do to make up for it,
underscore sweat, and then you just said that.
Like, like chat reflects the streamer, okay, and streamer reflects the chat.
So maybe, sorry, and thank you. I am so sorry. That was wildly inappropriate.
Me, when the stream gets taken down, like, ah, okay. Are you squidding me right now?
Truly, wholeheartedly. I'm sorry too. Sorry that we aren't in the straight line right now.
Like, it's locked. I don't know how to get into it. I think if we expand the store and
off and let me do that, I'm gonna very quickly buy some more products.
I like to sing, I like to dance, but I can't do it with a pew pew in my pants. Got focused.
Look, I'm working out, look, the reason why stock is low, you're gonna shit your pantyloons
when you realize stock is low because you guys are buying all the stock and I am a one-man army,
please. Lose, just buy the tea. Okay, he's actually buying like tons of tea though. Thank you.
Eggs and tea, that's what I like to sing. I'm down for apocalyptic. What? I'm down apocalyptic
for strong. What? Apocalyptic? What? Apocalyptic. Oh, apocalyptic is a word. Yes, it is a word,
actually. Now that you mentioned it, apocalyptic is a word. Okay, I'm done. I'm not speaking for
the rest of the stream. Whoa, I can't even speak English. Right, water. Pop it there.
Eggies. Pop it there. Okay. Whoa, I thought we were finished with customers. Jump scare,
honestly, geez. Down the apoliptical, honestly, isn't that a machine in a gym? The apoliptic is?
I cannot freaking speak right now. I'm starting and stammering. Someone clipped when I was very
kindly gifted like 10 memberships and I was like, I was just an absolute shambles. It was a shambles.
Right, let's clean this up. We've got a few, just a few deliveries, just a few deliveries. Right,
we'll clean all this up, we'll do one more date and then I'm redirecting into Sheebie and there's
nothing you can do about it. You're getting loved on by the bun. She got buns of steel, okay? You're
getting loved on by the bunny. She's an ASMR. Please subscribe. She's almost hit 10,000 subscribers,
which is freaking awesome. As I said, the girls are like, they're just so fantastic and they're so
excited to reach these milestones because it's like, that's right, Strani give up on speaking English
and just bark for us. Stop! Make sure you get a good reward. It's so anonymous. Stop.
I have another week to wait. I have a whole week. I can't do anything for a week. Knock it off.
I'll start barking orders at you. Thank you for the tip though. And Momo, thank you for the tip
with the pew pew. Any purers? Any self-identified purers? I pee. I pee my pants. Sorry. I don't know
why I always make that joke. I don't know. I find it funny. Yes, also Sheebie's dream. Well,
Sheebie said she wanted a play button. So I told all the girls I will do everything I possibly can
to achieve a play button for you goofy gibbers. So if you didn't know, I have fantastic news. If
you're a clipper, Veilure is coming out with a clipping program very soon TM. And the current,
now you do have to apply and be accepted for it. You can't just automatically get it overnight. But,
but for every 1000 views you get, we have, we are going to trial $2 per every 1000 views you get
in the clipper program because we want to say a special thank you for taking the time to go
through VODs and edits. So we're going to offer $2 per 1000 views and the ceiling price is 100k.
So for one clip you could in theory get $200. However, it does have to have an expiry date
because we can't like pay you out like three years after, you know, the clips are, you know, the girls
are, you know, um, but if the clip gets over 100k views, but it reaches like a next milestone,
you also get like a bonus on top, but it's not 2000 per views. Like cause I didn't,
I didn't want to insult why am I standing here? Bro, it's the end of the day. Right. One more day.
Well, just give me one more day. Just give me one more day. What do I need? I need cereal.
I need a lot. Right. What do I need cereal? There's already flour. I need oil.
Water? Are you squidding me right now? More cheese. Why not? We'll buy all that in the month.
Screw the two dollars. For every 1000 views I want licking the ear from mama.
Oh, well, I've got that coming out. I need to edit it. It goes on Twitter for free. There's going
to be tons of ear licking content on Twitter because I recorded tons of fun ear licking and
then it never happened. Day 12, store income. Oh, yeah. Right. Uh, let's very quickly order this.
Order. Come on. Come on. Come on. I've never restocked harder in my life.
Come on. Before the customers come in. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Let's do it. Let's do
it. Let's do it. Oh, wait. We already have oil. Oh, I need cereal. Why did I buy that? I need
cereal. Cereal. Do we need bread? Be honest. Do we need bread? No, that's bread there.
More sugar. I mean, we can just buy whatever at this point then. Oh, open. Open. Quick. Quick.
Right. Let's buy more bread.
Oil. Hell yeah. Oil.
Like I always said, oil. Are you American? Thank you as Richie and Momo as well. There's
going to be tons that you're licking. I promise. Just let me cook in a week. Let me, there'll be
so much cooking in a week. You have no idea. Do you call fish? Do you call fish? Do you call
fish? Sorry. I got, I got effing on my mind because of that freaking storage room thingy.
Why are you paying so much? Go. At my face. Let her cook what's for dinner.
I'm a full fish. Wait, what was the statement? I forgot. Do you call fish even have a tongue
for licking? Eh, not really. It would really be all done by the tentacle of things. But I have
eight. What the shit? I showed my dad my mech assault stream and he said hi to you all
whilst we were watching the board. I was like, so those are the reeflands and they all say hi to
me and we're all having a giggle. He really liked the scene where I was panicking in the
mech assault map where it was like you pretend to be an enemy because you're going to soot
or basically. He was like laughing at that and he was like reading all your chat and he was like,
your chat, my chat. Sorry, I'm trying to do it from his perspective. He was reading it and he was
like, whoa, they're really interactive. And I'm like, yeah, like that's like the fun of streaming
is like you get to talk live. They get to read your comment because like I explain to him like
I got explained to him that I got explained to me that when the streamer reads out your comment,
like it gives you a little serotonin boost. Like you ready? She AFK. She has brain rot. It's over.
Strong is going to be cooking so much so there's barely going to be any loudest fucking eagle sounds.
Give me fuel. Give me fire. Give me that witch I desire. Oh, hi pops and we cry when she disappears.
Hi papa. Oh yeah. What did you think of everyone wanting to marry? He finds it but he loves it.
He loves it. He has one question for you. Celtic arrangers. You have to pick. That's his question
for you. Basically. Basically. Yeah. Read mine too. Yeah. Yeah. Take that serotonin.
Take that serotonin boost. That's right. I'm reading what you're saying. What you can do about it.
What was the question? Maybe Celtic? Yes. Ah, yes. The ball. I love sports games.
Exactly. Celtic. Celtic. True. Read mine too. It's a super nice. True. Exactly. Get serotonin boost
Celtic. Exactly. That's right. Get that serotonin boost. The streamer has said
Lord give me one more chance. I love that song. It's so good. As if I can do any of that. Get
serotonin. Get serotonin. Hey you. I want to talk to your manager. The other day when I was here
you didn't have any cheese. Also the eggs my friends son bought tasted to eggy. Some eggs tasted
to eggy. Karen your comments about my shop are unfounded and I do not appreciate them. Karen
please leave your review and go. Thank you so much for the tip. Karen. No way. No way you're on
another account. I'll buy this place to build a kanzio here. You want to what? I'll buy this place
to build a casino. You want a casino? No. Gamble bad though. Gamble only good in Baltic. In Baltic
and Baltral. Why did I say Baltic? Baltic means cold in Scots. It's like oh that's Baltic. That's
reason. A casino. Oh come on. Come on. Come on. Give customer Greg's son-in-law a chance. Okay he's
allowed to. Well you never started on a word before or spelt something wrong. How dare you? How dare
you? You think you're so high and mighty the way you've never started in your life before. I'm
coming for you. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Get happy. Get happy. Get happy. Gamble is only good
in gacha games. Baltic. Yeah. It's like oh that's reason. That's Baltic. Is that a Stonia flag?
Is in the Balkans? No. Is that a Stonia flag? Am I going crazy? I'm sure that's a Stonia flag.
A Stonia I mentioned. I really hope you're coming for me.
You think I'm not? You think this is a joke huh? Strip poker. Well it's called sounds like a high
stakes game. What does that mean? Is that a pun or is that like a sentence? I'm so sorry. I don't
have my brain on me right now. What's wrong? Couldn't find the cheese. You just bought the cheese.
Am I going crazy? Rewind the void. Did she not just buy the last cheese and then complain that
she couldn't find the cheese? Uh, Madame, you are the problem. Right, I'm not going to restock
because we're going to redirect into Sheepsters doing her VA some more. And then I'm not going to
play this offline but please don't be surprised if I go nuts for another version of this, like
another stream of this game. I'm sorry but this gameplay, money go up and then I can unlock a
refling and I can like sexually harass you at the till and stuff. Like come on, come on. That's
right, grab that war. Buy my products. You love the store. You love the store. Get off the stage.
100 bucks. Oh come on, be realistic. Be realistic. You're lucky I can do math. Oh I'm level 10. I
can hire a refling but I'm not going to have enough money to do it. But we'll do it again, okay?
I can afford, you can afford a cashier. Well I need to buy the thing as well. I actually,
you need to buy the cashier and you need to,
what do I need to, I don't know, I don't know. Oh my god, I'm getting stressed again. There's
too many customers. Why do you all come at once? I'm getting nervous. I'm getting nervous. Why do
you all come at once? She says, she said, aha that's what she said. No seriously, why do you all
pile up? By the last moment please. I'm getting stressed. Thank you for your custom but I'm getting
stressed. Right there's one more, one more customer and I think we're done. What is it? Oh no it's 8
p.m. There's a whole flock of new customers about to come in. Mummy likes tycoon games. Look, I do.
You know what game I really enjoy? And literally no one's played it. On the Nintendo DS there's
this game called Zoo Tycoon and you can like make all the animals happy in it and I adore that game.
It's like such a simplistic one. I don't know if I can make a stream out of it though. I think it's
a bit too boring but I love it. Folk leave in their offices there's a lot of them. It's trying to
get more vague Rievelin. You will be so damn bad for Sukiya. Will I actually be Suika? Suika. Suika.
Okay Suika. I'm very interested and I have a stream with Azura tomorrow. I'm so excited. I know you
can't see it but I need to put it up. No change. Thank you for the exact change. What would you like?
A card? Absolutely my good sir. Thank you. You know you look like that guy that just came in
two seconds ago. I don't know if you noticed that but hey ho. Caring for animals? I'm sold.
I play two three games every day. You play a variety of games every day? I like stick to one
game. I get addicted to one. Like thanks to streaming, unironically I get to play games for the first
time and just see what I enjoy. In June I got to play a buckshot roulette and that was fun as heck.
I did not expect how fun that was going to be. I am humping my desk for when the multiplayer comes
out. I'm sorry I'm gyrating. I think we're closed. I think we're closed. Lights out. What a beautiful
store. I will come back. I hear birds tweeting in game. We'll just have a little
is that in game or is that real life?
It may be real life. I'm sorry. It may be real life. There's birds tweeting. I forgot it's morning.
I forgot. It's 6 a.m. sorry. I just want to take an investigation around here. Is there like
anything in particular or is it just kind of a map? Hmm it seems to be that. Reef flanks!
Let me in! Reef flanks! I need my ink supply!
I start badgering your homes. Wake up! Wake up Reef flanks! Are you squidding me right now?
Let me in! I find this game boring but you make it entertaining as I got a stroke writing this.
Oh thank you Momo. I've thoroughly enjoyed this game but I can understand maybe the
gameplay a bit. Dry cleaners! Wake up! My uniform's dirty because of my reef flanks.
Only real strongy knocking if you knock eight times. You can knock on random strangers' houses.
Reef flanks I know you're in there. I didn't realize how big the map is like. Holy moly!
It's like an eight block. Oh there's a carcass. Uh sir?
Sir you're causing a carcass. Sir you need to you need to back up. Sir your your your
suspension's gone. You have no turning. What is going on here? Fresh! Fresh shut the
shower. At least with baby powder. What are you saying? Oh you're just a number.
Sir you're literally causing a traffic jam. How am I supposed to get deliveries if you're in the
way? Whoa! He just phased through that taxi. I too phased through the taxi. Are you squeezing me right now?
He is like two dollars I think. Thank you piano emu 1120 that's such a specific gamer tag I'm so
sorry. Thank you for your two dollars! Yank my two dollars now it's going to invest in my conglomerate.
I'm going to become the monopoly I swore to destroy in Momo thank you. And customer great
son-in-law thank you and anon! I wonder if I could train you to respond to anon as well as refling
like anonymous breaking news crazy shop owner knocking in the middle of the night on everyone's
doors to ask for ink uh from a person called refling honestly though. Ooh I can see the texture
of the map outline. I can see under the map which means we can fall under it. Fall under the map
in my video game store. This is wait what where do you go or did they just walk around infinitely?
I think they maybe just walk around infinitely you know that. Are you a night walker?
They go into their homes! Oh they've like actually put detail into this game sorry sorry but this
game has pleasantly surprised me. I'll say it it's I am so surprised by this game I I I understand
I'm sorry to all v-tubers that I watched play this game and then I said damn you guys are
really taking this trend huh it's a good game I enjoy it okay mommy don't go into the background
oh let's let's try and break it into your house to steal your ink ASMR don't think I won't write
that I will write it right now okay I will write everything right now get me a week and we can
cook in a week okay right let me make sure I'm gonna redirect success uh the bluetooth device is
uh redirected successfully into my genme right right sheebie is doing uh cheeky ASMR so it's
probably gonna be uh a bit nice and quiet or honestly um but please don't be afraid to subscribe
and like sheepsters as uh stream because I think she's like so close to 10k what's she at hold on
let me listen to something best again she be cotton bum who named her honestly um
she's 90 subscribers off of 10k oh she might hit it to stream oh my god I'm literally gonna
bomb into her stream until everyone to like and subscribe okay she's so close I'm so happy for
I'm so freaking happy I'm so happy I miss you already strongy please you'll have you'll be fed up
with me in a week's time you're gonna be so fed up with me of how many streams are coming out next
week I'm not even kidding now the start of the week I can't do all the streams but then after that
I hope you have stamina for the end of July because uh yeah it's over for you and your pintas
okay I said what I said um but yeah if you're looking for a game that's chill and you can just
like listen to stuff in the background with if you just want to watch like stuff in the
background whilst you play a mindless game I am giving this game a 10 out of 10 I am not even
kidding this is the kind of game that's so chill and relaxed and like such a goof in a gaff I highly
recommend it please please check it out if you've got the money and you want to support the dev team
as far as I'm aware it's not AAA studio I like support in the wee guys okay so yes strongy seal
of approval I will be mentioning this at my July review impossible you're too entertaining stop that
refling stop being giving stop being so nice to me or else I'm going to give you a Kim yeah you
like shopping at my my shop yes you do refling that's right keep giving me your money good
refling wow help me expand my domain
um if ASMR isn't your thing then Emmy Beezoo is live with Dempah Fisher they're drawing together
so don't be shy don't be shy check them out oil my clock up for faster time travel you can't wait
aww refling thank you as a Ryuji I'm so sorry for pronouncing everything's horrifically wrong
you guys need to start calling yourself car so I can say your name super easily okay nah I dink
the secret to free advertisement of your story is giving Commander Shepard a discount what it won't
be money but I will certainly give you a tip more oh wait I said that out loud with so much
confidence without actually reading the contents of that comment I'm so sorry I literally oh it's
a massive fake reference I was so sorry I read that out with full confidence without actually
reading the content of that um have a good rest I will I'm gonna have a little nap um
and then I what do I need to do today um all day so everyone should have two ASMRs up okay
I changed my name because it was too hard oh did you actually thank you Momo because I can
read your names so easily got her got her you're making me blush that's my jaw refling it's my jaw
Stony please never stop kissing do you like the kisses out there in the stream I like them
the kisses I think it's cute sorry it's the tongue tracking coming out whilst I do that
because you know how much I'm sticking my tongue out like honestly normally I can tell which lips
you're kissing with but I'm not so sure at the moment excuse me add on are you serious I just dropped
my bottle lid are you serious hold on let me pick my lid up for your water oh add on just to say that
shock and behavior um but yes please oh I'm still in game I didn't even realize
oops well I'm glad the time has a pause thing I'll take that okay please fantastically enjoy
she be caught in boom can we get a Scottish Irish mix I'm not Irish unfortunately I do apologize
well I mean if you want to if you want to get technical then yeah I guess genetically
um but yeah right no more don't know it's not about the oil man next stream three
what you're just gonna strip off and come into the shop naked wow covered in oil so we can't grab
you how dare you right no more no more being no more supporting me financially stop it I'm about
to go off stream no more and what if she kisses us with both at the same time oh I can do that at
the same time yeah I just need to get on top of you I was like how is that possible but I'd be kissing
your lower parts as well you're tentacle okay thank you so so much what is the order to become a
veal or cutlery it comes out on August 1st you'll see us tweeting about it you're not going to miss
that August 1st is when all that stuff happens um but please understand you might not get accepted
um we have to be very strategic because it's a lot of money to invest in clips in the way that
we're setting up and it's two dollars per 1000 views but you know there's gonna be as as always with
the website everything will be laid out it'll be crystal clear how the setup works do not worry
it's uh before we go you're at 13.8k you'll be 14k in a few hours I'm gonna cream stop supporting me
get supported I can't take your support anymore it's so big you'll never get me alive stop right
thank you for the tip Momo but keep your money I'm going offline but I can't handle your support
the debt grows the debt grows honestly one week you guys are gonna be shocked at how much ASMR is
coming out um literally you guys are gonna be horrified horrified no you're not gonna be horrified
you're gonna get support get support I should actually unironically I might make a Twitter
audio like that being like I can't handle your support and you know doing the rest of the stuff
that happens in a Twitter audio you know how it is why did I just snail blink stop snail blinking
I'm blinking normal I promise no not going to stop okay right I'm going offline then you've
done it now the plan never changes 20k before the 10k celebration is my dream what for AC or am I
being really dumb I might be being dumb reeflings I couldn't possibly play or all this ASMR deck
can I paint some other way right I'm going to disappear please enjoy she be I'm going to do
some behind the scenes work uh because I actually need to prepare the document uh for the clipping
program oh well I mean bye thank you okay goodbye reeflings I'll see you if you give us tomorrow
for some salvation I don't know how to say it I'll see you tomorrow have fun and I'm also playing
with Azur tomorrow as well and we were here I hope you like puzzles and I hope you like
brainless people well actually I don't know if Azur is brainless I know I'm brainless for a fact so
yeah I'll see what happens I don't think Azur has actually played it before I have played
the game before but I don't remember much of it from being honest take me to the moon and let me
play among the stars fly me to the moon and let me play among the stars let me see what spring is
like yeah that the the bayonetta song that's why I know that song because it's from bayonetta
what do you mean it's from frank sinatra don't say such things it's bayonetta copyright bayonetta
okay okay all right I'm gonna get going because I need to go rest and then I need to do some
behind the scenes work for the clipping program which I'm so excited to and so please look out for
if you are a clipper if you're a clipper and a shipper don't make me sing along I legit didn't
know it before bayonetta literally I'm bayonetta brainwreck I can't wait to play with you as well
flock off she says flock off instead of in other words really kiss me
okay I see you good for goober's tomorrow please enjoy shebe's ASMR and don't be afraid to hit
subscribe oh don't forget to hit that like and subscribe button
I'm so bad it does not I'm so bad anyway don't don't she be not doing her okay I see tomorrow
reeflings on so we car I see you tomorrow love you
love you bye okay love you bye love you bye
enjoy shebeem oh wait I need to confirm that I'm definitely redirected into her okay I confirmed
oh I'm in game no no no no right love you